RBL
Sénat bonjour à tous retour ce matin à
la séance d'hier pendant toute la soirée
les sénateurs ont débattu du projet de
loi nom qui prévoit une nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
ce projet de loi a été adopté le 15 juin
dernier à l'Assemblée nationale et
prévoit plus d'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est une obligation pour la
France qui doit transposer les
directives européennes qui prévoient
cette évolution c'est le géant français
EDS qui est le principal visé par cette
loi il devra concéder a pris coûant
un/art de sa production nucléaire à ses
concurrents mais surtout ce projet de
loi pourrait avoir une incidence sur les
prix pour l'industrie mais aussi pour
les consommateurs tout de suite
direction l'hémicycle pour la discussion
générale sur le projet de loi nom une
séance présidée par Catherine taskaa
très bonne séance à vous l'ordre du jour
rappelle la discussion du projet de loi
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale portant
nouvelle organisation du marché de
l'électricité dans la discussion
générale la la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Louis borlau ministre d'État
ministre de l'écologie de l'énergie du
développement durable et de la mer en
charge des technologies vertes et des
négociation sur le
climat monsieur le ministre vous avez la
parole
madame la la
présidente monsieur le Président de la
commission de l'économie du
développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire cher
Jean-Paul et Maine monsieur le
rapporteur cher ladisl mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs permettez-moi
tout d'abord de vous dire tout le
plaisir que nous avons avec Benoît
Apparu et Valérie lettat à nous
retrouver devant vous pour l'examen en
première lecture de ce projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation du marché
de
l'électricité quelques semaines ou
quelques mois après des débats déjà très
riches devant l'Assemblée nationale en
juin et devant votre commission au mois
de juillet
dernier je voudrais avant de commencer
remercier très sincèrement les membres
de votre commission son président
Jean-Paul et Maine votre rapporteur
Ladislas patovski pour tout le travail
effectué en amont sur un texte
extrêmement technique mais absolument
essentiel pour la compétitivité de notre
pays vous me permettrez d'associer
également à ces remerciements vos
collègues de la commission des affaires
économiques de l'Assemblée nationale
ainsi que les membres de la commission
chanssort donc une fois de plus Ladislas
poetovski ainsi que jean-Marc Pastor
dont le rapport final remis au mois
d'avril 2009 a largement inspiré
l'architecture du texte que nous
soumettons aujourd'hui à votre examen
j'exprime aussi ma gratitude à
Jean-Claude Merceron qui avec le
président Emorine et votre rapporteur a
accompagné le gouvernement dans la
préparation la compréhension et la pédag
de ce texte avant d'aller plus loin dans
le détail du texte permettez-moi de
revenir brièvement sur les raisons qui
nous ont conduit à vous proposer ce
projet de loi que je crois capital pour
notre avenir un projet de loi qui
intervient dans un contexte où le prix
de l'électricité est en moyenne de 30 %
inférieur à la moyenne européen ce qui
constitue un avantage majeur en terme de
compétitivité de pouvoir d'achat et que
nous devons opérativement préservé un
contexte dans lequel nous ressentons à
nouveau le besoin d'investir massivement
dans nos réseaux de distribution dans
nos infrastructures et dans notre parc
de production
d'électricité afin d'améliorer son
coefficient de disponibilité et donc son
efficacité je rappelle qu'à certaines
périodes de l'année la France est
importatrice net d'électricité ce qui
est difficilement concevable un contexte
dans lequel il ne s'agit pas de désigner
des responsables mais tout simplement de
prendre nos responsabilités sereinement
collectivement afin de proposer enfin un
cadre juridique suffisamment stable pour
permettre aux acteurs de la filière
électrique de programmer leurs
investissements sur le long terme
personne ne conteste aujourd'hui la
nécessité de faire évoluer une
réglementation qui n'est plus en mesure
de garantir la pérénité de notre modèle
énergétique en raison notamment d'une
instabilité chronique avec près de 7
lois votées en 10 ans et de nombreuses
dispositions provisoires dans la
dernière endate adopté à l'initiative du
sénateur poniatovski concernant le
principe de réversibilité qui est
absolument nécessaire pour protéger les
droits des consommateurs d'un manque de
lisibilité également au niveau des
tarifs avec des offres librees des
tarifs réglementés le tartame et des
règles différenciées de migration d'une
offre vers l'autre
une insécurité juridique permanente
notamment au niveau européen qui a pour
principale conséquence de retarder les
investissements nécessaires des acteurs
de la filière électrique rappelle que la
France est actuellement sous le coup de
deux
contentieux le premier pour non
transposition de la directive 2003 54
qui concerne plus spécifiquement les
tarifs réglementés perçus par la
Commission comme des obstacles à
l'ouverture des
marchés mais un deuxième contentieux
surtout si j'ose dire pour suspicion
d'aide d'État en raison des pratiques
des tarif pratiqué actuellement en
faveur des entreprises moyennes et du
TaRTAM qui pourrait si rien n'est fait
déboucher sur des obligation de
remboursement considérable au dépend de
nos entreprises concernées par les
tarifs
réglementés j'ajoute que ce contentieux
à la différence du premier est
exécutoire par provision par provision
c'est-à-dire pourrait créer un véritable
cataclysme dans l'économie française
face à cette situation est dans un
secteur où les investissements
nécessitent une très forme visibilité à
long terme un pays comme la France ne
pouvait plus se contenter de procéder à
des ajustements à la marge en repoussant
sans cesse les réformes à plus tard je
précise qu'en l'absence de réforme nous
avions le choix entre deux mauvaises
solutions du moins deux mauvaises à nos
yeux de ce solution socialement et
stratégiquement inacceptable soit
renoncer à toute forme de régulation
soit se résoudre à démantel l'opérateur
historique avec dans les deux cas une
hausse brutale et continue des tarifs
les débats très approfondis menés au
sein de la Commission chanor ont permis
de faire émerger de façon assez
naturelle et consensuelle une troisième
voie nous permettant à la fois de
maintenir une régulation très forte tout
en restant fidèle aux trois piliers qui
fondent notre stratégie énergétique un
haut degré de
compétitivité une sécurité absolue de
nos
approvisionnements et l'adaptation vers
une politique électrique plus
respectueuse de l'environnement grâce
notamment à la maîtrise de la demande et
à la gestion de la pointe le dispositif
proposé par la Commission chansor
modifié par l'Assemblée nationale et
amendé par votre commission s'articule
ou s'organise autour de quatre principes
ou de quatre concepts clés c'est d'abord
ce que l'on a appelé l'accès régulé à la
base et qu'on appelle aujourd'hui pour
des raisons de précision et de clarté
l'accès régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique c'est-à-dire la possibilité
pour les concurrents d'EDF d'acquérir de
l'électricité pour l'approvisionnement
de leurs clients situé en France au coût
complet de production du parc nucléaire
historique autre dit au juste prix au
prix le plus équitable transparent et
opposable qui soit le projet de loi
définit ainsi clairement les composants
de ce prix régulé qui devra dans un
premier être dans un premier temps
cohérent avec le TaRTAM et dont
l'objectif sera sur la durée de la
période de régulation de couvrir
strictement les coûts de production du
parc nucléaire historique à savoir la
rémunération du capital les charges
courantes les investissement
d'allongement de durée de vie les
charges de long terme autrement dit la
gestion des déchets et du
démantèlement je rappelle que ce
dispositif est strictement encadré
puisqu'il est limité dans le temps il
est valable 15 ans limité en quantité et
qu'il prévoit des clauses de revoyure
tous les 5 ans j'ajoute que les
fournisseurs qui décideront de revendre
plus cher à l'étranger l'électricité
achetée en France par laarinene cet axè
régulé à l'énergie nucléaire historique
pour augmenter
artificiellement leurs profit devront
rembourser la différence à DF sous peine
de sanction il s'agit de s'assurer
qu'ils ne disposeront d'aucun bénéfice
illégitime grâce à ce dispositif nous
faisons le choix d'une régulation forte
mais ciblée on passe en réalité d'une
régulation avale à une régulation amont
tout en ayant la certitude que nous
disposerons des moyens financiers
suffisants pour entretenir et développer
nos infrastructures énergétiques le
deuxième principe que nous devons à
votre collègue Bruno sidau et au député
Serge Poignant concerne la mise en place
d'une obligation de capacité
d'effacement ou de production don le but
est d'obliger les fournisseurs
alternatifs à participer au financement
de la sécurité des approvisionnements et
de mieux rémunérer l'effacement de la
consommation ainsi que la production de
pointe le projet de loi prévoit donc
l'obligation à comptter de 2015 pour le
fournisseur de disposer de façon directe
ou indirecte de suffisamment de capacité
de production ou d'effacement RTE
vérifiera chaque année que le
fournisseur d'tiens propres ou par
contrat des capacités d'effacement ou de
poes suffisantes les sanction pouvant
aller de la simple amende jusqu'au
retrait pure et simple du droit
d'exercer on passe donc d'une situation
dans laquelle ETF était assureur
implicite de tout le système à une
situation dans laquelle la charge est
mutualisée entre l'ensemble des
fournisseurs ce nouveau dispositif
permettra en N de développer la pratique
de l'effacement comme c'est le cas dans
de nombreux pays en parallèle ou en
complément du marché de l'effacement qui
sera effectif à compter de 2012 le
projet de loi prévoit la mise en place
de deux innovations que nous devons au
Parlement la première introduit un un
dispositif
d'interruptibilité en échange d'une
rémunération les très gros consommateurs
s'engagent à interrompre immédiatement
leur activité en cas de surcharge sur le
réseau la seconde innovation imaginé par
votre collègue Jean-Claude Vial et
soutenu par le gouvernement permet à RTE
de lancer des appels d'offre défacement
tout toujours en direction des gros
consommateurs j' reviens maintenant à la
question des tarifs réglementé pour
lesquels il s'agit de distinguer entre
petit consommateurs et gros
consommateurs en ce qui concerne les
petits consommateurs encla les
particuliers commerçants et artisans le
projet de loi prévoit le maintien des
tarifs réglementés et consacre le droit
de pour chacun de choisir librement et à
tout moment son distributeur en fonction
de ses besoins on a donc une
réversibilité totale et absolue ce qui
constitue une protection très forte pour
les
particuliers je crois d'ailleurs que
nous parlerons dans le cadre de l'examen
de ce texte de l'éventuelé d'une
extension au gaz de disposition du même
type s'agissant des consommateurs les
plus démunis nous pensons vons réfléchir
dès à présent à la meilleure façon de
les aider dans leur accès aux tarifs
sociaux en ce qui concerne les gros
consommateurs le projet de loi prévoit
la suppression des tarifs réglementés à
compter 2015 dans la mesure où les
entreprises auront désormais la
certitude que leurs fournisseurs
bénéficient du prix d'achat le plus
compétitif qu' soit à elle ensuite de
faire jouer la concurrence pour obtenir
les services commerciaux et les services
de transport les mieux adaptés à leurs
besoins nous le voyons les consommateurs
sont ainsi protégés un dernier mot
peut-être au sujet de la de la creux
dont le projet de loi prévoit d'étendre
à la fois les pouvoirs et les
attributions le texte permet également
d'aller vers une plus grande
professionnalisation avec C commissaires
à temps plein après concertation entre
l'Assemblée et la commission de
l'économie au lieu de Neu commissaires
dont six à temps partiel pr précédemment
le projet de loi marque la fin de la
représentation catégorielle et prévoit
une articulation renforcée entre la
creux et la CSE dont nous reparlerons
tout à l'heure nous avons donc un
régulateur qui dispose désormais des
moyens financiers et humains nécessaires
à l'accomplissement de sa mission de
service publ tels sont les objectifs
poursuivis par ce texte qui est à la
fois un texte de refondation juridique
de consolidation de notre compétitivité
industrielle et de protection de notre
consommateur je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Ladislas
poniatovski rapporteur de la commission
de
l'économie
merci merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je voudrais moi aussi Monsieur
le Ministre commencer par des
remerciements il se trouve que je suis
depuis très longtemps les problèmes
d'énergie en général d'électricité en
particulier je le faisais déjà à
l'époque où j'étais député et je le fais
depuis que je suis sénateur
et j'ai particulièrement apprécié
d'avoir été associé 1 en amont sur ce
texte le fait que vous ayez voulu
associer les deux rapporteurs de
l'assemblée du
Sénat nous ont déjà dès le début permis
d'apporter un certain nombre de
modifications sur le texte initial sur
lequel vous avez travaillé et pour un
rapporteur C c'est un moment agréable
mes chers collègues l'objet principal du
projet lo comme vient de nous le
rappeler monsieur le ministre que nous
allons
examiner son objet principal est
d'apporter une réponse à la faiblesse de
la concurrence sur le marché français de
l'électricité qui nous est reproché
comme vous disiez monsieur le ministre
en droit l'ouverture de ce marché est
complète depuis le 1er juillet
2007 mais chacun peut constater que dans
les faits l'opérateur historique a
conservé une position très largement
dominante et des F assure toujours 90 %
de la production d'électricité et
surtout
grâce au maintien des tarifs réglementés
F à conserver en volume plus de 95 % de
la clientèle résidentielle et près de 87
% de la clientèle non
résidentielle un sondage récent même
révélé que près de 40 % des Français ne
savaient même pas qu' pouvait acheter de
l'électricité à des électriciens
concurrents
d'df cette situation contraste avec les
évolutions observées dans les pays
européens voisins où les opérateurs
historiques ont dû se défaire d'une
partie de leur capacité de production au
profit de nouveaux entrants la
Commission européenne conteste cette
exception française et monsieur le
ministre vous le rappeliez à l'instant
la commission engageait en 2006 une
procédure en manquement contre la France
qui vise le maintien des tarifs
réglementés et à nouveau en 2007 une
procédure d'examen au titre des aides
d'État qui pourrait conduire les
entreprises françaises à devoir
rembousser plusieurs milliards d'euros
il nous est donc impossible de nous
satisfaire du statut quo le projet de
loin nomme s'inscrit dans la droite
ligne des propositions de la Commission
chansor qui a proposé de mettre en place
pour les fournisseurs alternatifs un
mécanisme d'accès régulé à l'électricité
de base produite par EDF à partir de son
parc de centrale nucléaire c'est ce
mécanisme qui a été rebaptisé depuis
accès régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique
Aren reoptisé par l'Assemblée nationale
et c'est ce mécanisme qui est mis en
place par l'article 1 de ce projet de
loi ce dispositif a été présenté au
commissaire européen chargé de la
concurrence et de l'énergie
et ceux-ci en ont approuvé le principe
et fait savoir que l'adoption du projet
de loi pourrait conduire à l'abandon des
procédures engagées ce texte préserve
deux acquis essentiels d'une part
l'intégrité d'df qui n'aura pas à céder
une partie de son outil de production
d'autre part le bénéfice de la
compétitivité du parc nucléaire
demeurera réservé aux consommateurs
français en effet les fournisseurs
alternatifs n'auront droit à l'arinene
qu' hauteur des besoins de leurs clients
en
France je voudrais maintenant évoquer
les perspectives d'évolution des prix de
l'électricité pour les petits
consommateurs vous l'évoquez monsieur le
ministre ceuxci resteront déterminés par
les tarifs réglementés que le projet de
loi pérénise en dessous d'une puissance
de 36 kV AMP pour les
autres les autres consommateurs la mise
en place de l'arè permet d'envisager la
suppression des tarifs réglementés
au-delà du 31 décembre 2015
au total des prix de l'électricité
demeureront plus bas en France que dans
la plupart des autres pays européens
toutefois
toutefois il faut avoir bien conscience
qu'une augmentation modérée et
progressive des prix d'électricité est
nécessaire après l'effort financiers
consentis par les français dans les
années 1970 et 1980 pour constituer le
parc de centrale nucléaire les tarifs
réglementés ont connus à partir du
milieu des années 1990 une diminution en
terme réel contenu de
l'inflation or nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui face à d'importants besoins
d'investissement pour améliorer la
qualité des réseaux les réseaux de
transport et ce distribution
souvenez-vous des problèmes des pannes
généralisé que nous avons connu et en
Bretagne et en région PACA mais nous
avons des besoins aussi pour couvrir la
progression de la demande en période de
pointe et bientôt pour prolonger la
durée de vie des centrales cette
évolution inévitable des prix de
l'électricité est tout à fait
indépendante de la loi Nome ce texte
définit simplement les procédures de
fixation des tarifs réglementés et de
laarine qui seront confiés au ministres
compétents et à la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie il n'en
détermine pas les niveau qui résulteront
d'un calcul économique rigoureux je
considère donc comme un argument les
prises de position cherchant à établir
un lien entre la loi nom qui ne sera
promulguée j'espère avant la fin de
l'année au plus tard dans les premières
semaines de l'année 2011 et par ailleurs
la hausse des prix de l'électricité la
preuve ils sont intervenus le 15 août
dernier en tant que
rapporteur je reconnais la complexité du
mécanisme de la reine les droits de
chaque fournisseur d'électricité seront
fondés sur une évaluation ex-anté de son
portefeuille de client en France puis
ils feront l'objet d'un contrôle expost
qui pourra donner lieu au versement d'un
complément de prix s'il apparaît qu'ils
ont en fait excédé la consommation
effective de ses
clients le travail de la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie la creux à qui
est confié la surveillance du mécanisme
sera particulièrement délicat les
ajustements législatifs du dispositifs
seront probablement assez vite
nécessaires et c'est pourquoi des
rendez-vous sont prévus tous les 5 ans
pour son évaluation devant le
Parlement le gouvernement avait deux
autres choix soit comme chez nos voisins
italiens et allemands vous évoquiez vous
l'évoquez monsieur le ministre demander
à l'opérateur historique de céder une
part plus ou moins conséquente de ses
moyens de production je vous rappelle
mes chers collègues qu'en Italie nel a
dû céder 15 de ses 56 GW de capacité
aujourd'hui NL ne contrôle plus que
1/ers du marché italien
d'ailleurs et vous ne l'ignorez pas EDF
est présente à travers sa filiale Edison
le marché allemand d'électricité était
dès le départ moins concentré puisque
partagé entre quatre grands acteurs mais
ceux-ci ont également dû céder des
actifs de production et aujourd'hui les
opérateurs français EDF et Gaz de Fran
Suise détiennent près de 19 GW de
capacité de production en
Allemagne pour ma part je défends et
monsieur le ministre comme vous en aucun
cas je n'aurais souhaité qu'eds soit
obligé d'abandonner une partie de son
parc
nucléaire pour ma part je défends une
solution alternative qui aurait le
mérite de permettre également le
développement de la concurrence tout en
étant moins complexe cette solution vous
la connaissez car je me suis déjà
exprimé en commission et publiquement il
s'agit du développement des
participations industrielles dans le
pque de centrale nucléaire d'EDF plutôt
que de contraindre EDF à cder une partie
de sa production à ses concurrents je
pense qu'il aurait été plus simple et
plus efficace d'ouvrir la propriété de
ces centrales nucléaires au
participation des autres fournisseurs et
des gros consommateurs d'électricité
c'est c'est une solution qui n'est pas
sans
précédent ainsi Gaz de France Suise
détient 12,5 % dans la centrale
nucléaire de
trcastin la centrale de fenheim est
ouverte à hauteur de 17,5 % à une
participation de l' opérateur allemand
EnBW et de 15 % à une participation d'un
consortium de 3 opérateurs suisses
conduit par alpique les centrales de
chose et de catenom sont également
ouvertes à des participations
industrielles et puis je vous rappelle
mes chers collègues que le nouvel opère
de flamandville qui est en cours de
construction est ouvert à une
participation de 12,5 % d'El et celui de
panli qui est en projet à des
participations à la fois d'El d'on et de
Total ce système permet à EDF de
partager le risque industriel et
financier à ses associés d'avoir un
droit de tirage sur l'électricité mais
EDF reste le propriétaire l'exploitant
et le décideur une opportunité monsieur
le ministre se présentera dans les
prochaines années avec la prolongation
de la durée de vie d'exploitation des
centrales existantes
EDF a commencé à présenter des demandes
à l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire pour la
prolongation de 10 ans de ces centrales
les plus anciennes dont la durée de vie
serait portée de 40 à 50 ans à terme en
fait EDF vise une prolongation de durée
de vie de 20 ans pour qu'elles aient 60
ans de durée d'existence lors de son
audition devant notre commission
Monsieur Henri progliot le PDG DDF a
évalué le coût de ses investissements à
600 millions d'euros par tranche
nucléaire le chiffre avancé par son
prédécesseur n'était que de 400 millions
d'euros si je retiens monsieur le
ministre une estimation moyenne entre
les deux de 500 millions le montant
total
d'investissement pour la prolongation de
l'ensemble des 59 réacteurs français
s'élève à 29 milliards d'euros et je
serais personnellement très favorable à
ce queedf dont chacun connaît
l'endettement
endettement qui ne s'améliorera pas
forcément si on oblige GDF à prendre
départ dans AR je le dis au passage ne
finance qu'une partie de ces investisss
colossal et accepte la participation des
autofournisseurs d'électricité mais
aussi de clients industriels ainsi ceci
acquéit un droit d'accès à la production
d'électricité nucléaire d'df qui
demeurerait cependant le seul opérateur
des centrales concernées cette solution
qui ne nécessite d'ailleurs pas
forcément l'intervention d'un projet de
loi demeure toujours possible l'État
français est actionnaire majoritaire
desdf monsieur le ministre en ce qui
concerne le projet de loi mes ch
collègues je voudrais maintenant vous en
rappeler les principales dispositions en
soulignant les apports de la commission
d'économie l'article 1 constitue le cœur
du texte puisqu'il met en place le
mécanisme d'accès régulier à
l'électricité de base maintenant devenu
nucléaire ce dispositif transitoire
prévu jusqu'au 31 décembre 2025 est
défini comme le droit pour les
fournisseurs alternatif d'acheter à EDF
un volume d'électricité globalement
plafonné à un prix représentatif des
conditions économiques de production du
parc historique des centrales
nucléaires ce mécanisme est administré
par la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie et les ministres chargés de
l'économie et de l'énergie sur cet
article 1er votre commission a préféré
confier à la creux les échanges
d'informations nécessaires pour
déterminer les droits des fournisseurs à
l'arène plutôt qu'à une entité
juridiquement indépendante qu'il aurait
fallu créer comme le souhaitaient les
députés nous avons également pris date
pour une future ouverture des centrales
d'EDF à des participations qui devra
être l'un des points traités par le
rapport que le gouvernement présentera
au Parlement en 2015 l'article 2 est une
disposition importante qui fait
obligation à chaque fournisseur
d'électricité de contribuer à la
sécurité d'approvisionnement
national soit en construisant des
centrales soit en développement en
développant les capacités d'effacement
auxquels vous faisiez l'allusion
monsieur le tout à l'heure et vous avez
raison de préciser que la France a
beaucoup de retard par rapport à nos
voisins ces garanties de production
d'effacement doivent être conformes aux
prescriptions définies par le ministre
chargé de l'énergie après avis de la
creux en cohérence avec le programme
pluriannuel des investissements de
production d'électricité ces garanties
étant échangeables un marché de capacité
devrait être mis en place au cours des
prochaines
années votre commission a par ailleurs
introduit l'article 2 quater qui impute
au producteurs d'électricité les coûts
de raccordement de leur installation il
s'agit de modérer la charge financière
que représente pour
ERDF l'envolet des énergies
renouvelables notamment du
photovoltaïque je préfère que les moyens
financiers de RDF soi prioritairement
consacré à leur mission de service
public d'amélioration de son réseau de
moyenne
l'article 3 remplace la procédure
actuelle de déclaration des fournisseurs
d'électricité par une procédure
d'autorisation du ministre chargé de
l'électricité les deux articles suivants
du projet de loi initial conforent les
tarifs réglementés de vente
d'électricité l'article 4 modifie la
définition actuelle des tarifs
réglementés pour prévoir qu'ils soit
progressivement et au plus tard au 31
décembre 2015 établi par addition de
coût en tenant compte du prix de la
reine du coût du complément de
fourniture des coûts d'acheminement
ainsi que des coûts de commercialisation
la creux reçoit à terme compét pour
proposer les différents tarifs
réglementés mais durant une période
transitoire de 5 ans ceci continue
d'être arrêté par les ministres chargé
de l'énergie et de l'économie l'article
5 pérénise les tarifs réglementés de
vente d'électricité et de gaz pour les
petits consommateurs en réaffirmant le
principe de réversibilité et les
maintiens jusqu'au 31 décembre 2015 les
deux articles suivants du projet de loi
adaptent les missions de la composition
et de la Commission de régulation de
l'énergie la creux l'article 7 ajuste le
champ de compétence de la creux afin de
tenir compte de la mise en œuvre de
l'arine il donne notamment compétence à
la creux pour proposer les prix et
calculer les droits à la reine il étend
également le pouvoir de sanction dont
dispose la creux au cas d'abus ou
d'entrave au dispositifs de
laarineine l'article 8 prévoit une
réduction de 9 à 5 membres du collège de
la creux qui se trouvera ainsi composé
de trois membres dont le président nommé
par décret et deux membres nommés
respectivement par le président de
l'Assemblée nationale et par le
président du Sénat j'approuve totalement
les objectifs poursuivis par le
gouvernement s'agissant de cet article à
savoir disposer d'un collège resserré et
professionnalisé il est en effet anormal
que seul trois des ne9 membres du
collège exerce actuellement leur
fonction à plein tempemps et il est
malsin que plusieurs membres du collège
y représentent les intérêts de certains
acteurs du secteur de l'énergie en outre
l'article à l'article 8 votre commission
a rétabli à 5 membres pardon la
composition de la creux que l'Assemblée
nationale avait voulu réduire à trois
membres seulement j'ai toujours pas très
bien compris pourquoi les deux articles
suivants du projet de loi sont relatifs
à la transposition des directives du 3è
paquet énergie l'article 9 modifie le
code de la consommation afin de
transposer les dispositions relatives à
la protection des
consommateurs l'article 10 qui a été
supprimé je marrête quand même un
instant par l'Assemblée nationale avait
pour objet d'autoriser le gouvernement à
prendre par voie d'ordonnance dans un
délai de 9 mois les dispositions
nécessaires à la
transposition d'autres dispositions du
trème paquet énergie il s'agissait par
exemple de renforcer l'indépendance des
gestionnaires des réseaux de transport
d'électricité et de gaz mais sans
séparation patrmomiale ni gestion par
une société tierce alors mes chers
collègues je partage bien sûr la
position des députés qui ont estimé
cette question politiquement trop
importante pour pouvoir être transposée
par votre ordonnance mais Monsieur le
Ministre j'attire votre attention sur le
fait que ces directives doivent être
transposées avant le 3 mars prochain et
il ne sera pas facile de trouver un
créneau
législatif enfin le projet de loi
initiale s'achevait par un article 11
qui autorise les exploitants d'station
nucléaire à étaler dans le temps la
charge financière que représente
l'obligation de constituer des actifs
votre commission a introduit un article
11 bis qui prévoit que les gestionnaires
de réseau devront faire aux autorités
consédente un contte-rendu annuel sur le
politique d'investissement l'assemblée a
également adopté un certain nombre de
dispositions entièrement nouvelles qui
ont PL compléter le projet de loi
au-delà de ces 11 articles initiaux
l'article
12 réforme les taxes locales
d'électricité afin de les mettre en
conformité avec le droit communautaire
cette réforme est induite par une
directive européenne de 2003 la France a
été mise en demeure en mars dernier par
la commission car cette directive devait
être transposée avant le 1er janvier
2009 l'article 13 qui résulte d'un
amendement de Monsieur François Brotte
ajoute la société publique locale
dernièrement créée par la loi du 28 mai
2010 à l'initiative de notre de notre
collègue Daniel raou au formes juridique
proposé pour la fusion des entreprises
locales de distribution l'article 14 qui
résulte d'un amendement du rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nationale confirme que le
statut national des entreprises
électriques et gazières s'applique
également aux activités de
commercialisation c'est une précision
nécessaire pour assurer l'égalité des
conditions de concurrence entre les
fournisseurs historiques et les nouveaux
entrants enfin l'article 15 résulte d'un
amendement présenté par le gouvernement
pour proroger de 6 mois l'habilitation
qui lui a été donné pour adopter par
d'ordonnance la partie législative du
code de l'énergie outre les
modifications déjà incorporées en
juillet au texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui votre commission vous
propose SEP amendements additionnels
dont les principaux sont les suivants le
premier vise à préciser la mise en œuvre
du mécanisme d'obligation de capacité le
deuxième prévoit un barême national pour
le financement par RTE des travaux de
mise en souousterrain de ligne à haute
tension demandé par les collectivités
territoriales le trème donne compét à la
creux pour surveiller le marché des
garanties de capacité le 4e prévoit un
avis des commissions parlementaires
compétentes sur les nomination par
l'exécutif des deux membres de la creux
haut que son président le 5è précise les
délais de remboursement des trop perçus
par les fournisseurs d'électricité et
par ailleurs la la commission pardon a
décidé de donner un avis favorable à
certains des amendements présentés pour
la séance
publique je citerai les principaux un
amendement de Monsieur dangl prévoyant
une publicité
sur le site internet de la creux des
accords CADR entre EDF et les
fournisseurs alternatifs un amendement
de Monsieur Vial précisant que les
acteurs intéressés au prises de
participation pour être aussi bien des
fournisseurs d'électricité que des
consommateurs
électrointensif des amendements
identiques de monsieurs Pinta Besson et
CIN qui organisent l'attribution
automatique du tarif spécial de
solidarité pour le gaz un amendant de
Monsieur Merceron qui précise que le
futur marché des garanties capacité
devra prendre en compte l'interconnexion
avec les marchés européens un amendant
de Monsieur Vial qui donne mission à RTE
d'organiser un appel d'ofre pour la mise
en œuvre des capacités d'effacement
additionnelles des amendements
identiques de monsieurs Pinta Besson et
Merceron et CIN qui prévoit que le
compteendut annuel fait par le
gestionnaire de réseau à l'autorité
concédante devra porter sur son
programme prévisionnel d'investissement
enfin monsieur le ministre je voudrais
évoquer les derniers points sur lesquels
la position du gouvernement est attendue
de nombreux amendements demandent la
reconduction des contrats d'obligation
d'achat dont bénéficie les petits
installations les petites installations
hydraulique une reconduction pure et
simple de l'obligation d'achat n'est pas
possible mais je sais que votre
ministère travaille une solution qui
devrait donner satisfaction à ceux qui
exploitent à ceux des exploitants qui
vont réaliser de nouveaux
investissements plusieurs amendements
visent à conférer un caractère
automatique à l'attribution du tarif de
première nécessité pour
l'électricité l' amendement de notre
collègue Philippe adenau propose la
prolongation de durée de quelques mois
du TaRTAM pour éviter un vide entre la
mise en place de l'arine et l'arrivée à
l'échéance du dispositif du TaRTAM et
sous réserve d'une rectification j'y
suis favorable je vous attends monsieur
le ministre plusieurs amendements issus
de différents groupes politiques visant
à garantir la prod les pardon le produit
des taxes local d'électricité n'est-ce
pas monsieur le rapporteur en indexant
leurs tarifs soit sur l'évolution du
barême de l'impôt sur le revenu soit sur
l'inflation et je sais que notre
collègue Philippe Marini va nous faire
une proposition intéressante en la
matière un autre amendement de notre
collègue Philippe Marini identique
d'ailleurs à ceux de Madame desego et de
Monsieur mereron prévoit une
généralisation du régime d'assurance
chômage des entreprises de la branche
des industries électriques et gazières
je ne suis pas certain que cette
généralisation soit tout à fait
opportune mais votre ministère monsieur
le ministre s'est engagé à trouver une
solution monsieur le ministre pour
le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui a fait l'objet d'une large
concertation en Amand de son adoption
par le gouvernement j'ai procédé en tant
que rapporteur à une cinquantaine
d'auditions auquelles s'ajoutent les six
auditions que nous avons faites en
commission mon sentiment est que le
développement d'une concurrence
effective devra bénéficier au
consommateurs d'électricité les clauses
de rendez-vous prévu tous les 5 ans
pendant la durée du mécanisme
transitoire de l'arè nous permettront de
lui apporter des ajustements qui seront
nécessaires mais il est de notre
responsabilité de concevoir dès le
départ le meilleur dispositif possible
c'est pourquoi j'appelle mes collègues
sur tous les bancs à aborder cette
discussion dans un esprit constructif
afin que le projet de loi sorte encore
amélioré de nos débat je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe Marini rapporteur pour avis de
la commission des
finances
la présidente monsieur le ministre
d'État mes chers
collègues ce texte est original il
Inno car nous allons
créer un mécanisme de cession
forcé de son électricité par
EDF il s'agit d'organiser un système de
question forcée d'une partie environ
un/4 de l'électricité nucléaire dite
historique cession par EDF à ses
concurrents en d'autres termes
puisqueaucun autre opérateur n'est
capable de produire à des coûts aussi
bas
qu'EDF puisqu'il faut absolument qu'EDF
soit concurrencé en France et puisque
nul ne veut une une augmentation brutale
du prix de l'électricité pour nos
concitoyens comme pour nos
industriels il faut faire en sorte que
tous les fournisseurs actifs en France
puissent capter une partie du bénéfice
de la compétitivité du parc
électronucléaire
DDF je comprends les réticences de
certains mais je vous en prie
laissez-moi aller au bout de mon
développement et je pense que vous serez
peut-être un peu moins
véhément
alors pour tout vous dire et en toute
franchise je ne crois pas que la
solution que nous allons examiner que
par avance bien entendu j'accepte soit
complètement satisfaisante sur un plan
intellectuel je ne considère pas que le
modèle français qui a été en vigueur de
1945 à 2002 est
failli je ne le crois pas mais chers
collègues le droit communautaire
s'impose le rapporteur au fond et avant
lui le ministre
d'État a
rappelé attendez que je
poursuive mon propos est
objectif le rapport au fond et avant lui
le ministre d'État a rappelé les très
grands risques juridiques auxquels nous
exposerai l'inaction forte amende
astreinte remise en cause de l'ensemble
des tarifs réglementé voire obligation
pour les entreprises ce n'est pas
théorique de rembourser ce
qui il est de notre devoir d'agir et de
réformer un mot simplement pour rappeler
l'origine de ce droit communautaire mes
chers collègues nul ici ne doit oublier
que cette origine c'est le sommet de
Barcelone qui s'est tenu les 15 et 16
mars 2002 et que la France y était
représentée d'un côté par le Président
de la République Jacques Chirac et de
l'autre par le Premier ministre Lionel
Jospin
c'est à ce moment-là que la décision de
principe a été
prise la France a souscrit à ce
moment-là à la libéralisation des
marchés et il est vain d'espérer que
l'on puisse renégocier ces textes
puisque par définition notre mix
énergétique étant différent de celui des
autres nous ne pouvons qu'être isolés
sur une position de renégociation des
dirtiv je peux mais c'est la réalité des
choses beaucoup ici ont espéré la
renégociation un
jour il m'en souvient j'interrogeais
Christine Lagarde qui était à votre
place Madame le Ministre d'État et dans
un débat elle n'a pas hésité à répondre
monsieur le ministre d'État elle n'a pas
hésité à répondre et que oui dans
l'absolu il faudrait renégocier bien sûr
mais la réalité est ce qu'elle est nous
ne pouvons pas faire croire à nos
concitoyens qu'il soit possible de faire
bouger les principes le cadre de ce
droit
communautaire il ne faut
pas raconter d'histoirees à nos
concitoyens il y a là une vérité
juridique et contrôlable et il est de
notre devoir de l'aménager le mieux
et mes chers collègues en
conscience je pense que ce que l'on nous
propose c'est le cadre le plus régulé
possible le plus régulé que l'on puisse
raisonnablement espérer et qui soit
compatible avec le droit communautaire
faute de pouvoir réguler en aval en
contrôlant les prix de vente aux clients
nous régulerions en amont au niveau de
la relation producteur fournisseur et
ceci vaut certainement mieux j'espère
que vous sererez en accord là-dessus que
ne plus réguler du tout en laissant
naturellement les prix rejoindre ceux du
marché libre c'est-à-dire le prix de
production de la centrale la moins
performante et la plus polluante en
Europe ce qui est le principe directeur
du marché libre
si on le laisse fonctionner sans aucun
frein et sans régulation il est tout à
fait clair que ceci serait un désastre
pour le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs comme pour la
compétitivité de notre appareil
industriel donc ce qui fonde le texte
qui est devant nous c'est l'échange de
lettre entre le Premier ministre et les
deux commissaires européens
et même si l'aval ainsi donné est
informel il a permis d'avancer de la
même façon que les travaux de la
commission chansor ont débouché sur ce
consensus économique et technique qui
nous permet de donner de la visibilité
aux consommateurs
d'électricité donc la commission des
finances monsieur le ministre d'État
soutient euh ce texte en tout cas le
concept sur lequel repose ce texte mais
nous voudrions souligner que le succès
de cette législation nécessairement
complexe repose sur quelques conditions
plus exactement quatre conditions la
première c'est d'être très intransigent
sur
l'eurocomatibilité et je sais que cette
position est nécessairement partagée par
la commission de l'économie il n'est pas
possible dans cette discussion
parlementaire de prendre le moindre
risque à mon sens au niveau du moindre
amendement qui ne serait pas strictement
euro compatible en second lieu seconde
condition elle réside à mon avis dans
l'évolution dans le temps de ce
mécanisme d'accès régulé que va devenir
le plafond de 100 tawh par an comme
notre excellent rapporteur Ladislas
ponatovski comme l'Autorité de la
concurrence je pense que ce plafond
vocation à baisser au fil du temps
aujourd'hui il nous faut nous montrer
prudent et nous savons que nous
travaillons sous l'œil de nos amis de
nos excellents amis de la Commission de
l'Union européenne mais il devrait être
clair y compris de ce côté-là que
l'objectif de long terme de la nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
devrait être l'émer ence d'une
concurrence réelle à EDF fondé sur la
maîtrise d'outils de production
compétitif et non la perpétuation d'une
concurrence largement
artificielle quelque peu sous perfusion
de l'opérateur historique et à cet égard
se pose la question qui a été forte
opportunément évoquée par le rapporteur
au fond de prise de participation
minoritaire dans des centrales opérées
par PDF ce qui pourrait permettre en
effet de développer dans notre pays un
réel marché compétitif la troisième
condition de succès de ce projet de loi
monsieur le ministre d'État c'est
l'adéquation du prix de l'électricité
cédé par EDF à ses concurrents au
travers du mécanisme de
l'arè or la rédaction est telle que je
l'ai lu me semble encore un peu
ambigu initialement est-il est-il
affirmé ce prix doit être fixé en
cohérence avec le
tartare nous gagnerions à dire au moins
dans le débat à titre de bons travaux
préparatoires ce qu'il faut entendre par
là mon interprétation que j'ai livré
dans le rapport écrit de la commission
des finances l'inprétation de cette
phrase est qu'il s'agit au départ de
fixer un prix tel qu'un client au TaRTAM
puisseevir proposer une offre de marché
d'un niveau de prix identique compte
tenu de l'ensemble des coûts subi par
les opérateurs ainsi que d'une marge
raisonnable c'est-à-dire relativement
réduite ensuite et une fois passé cette
phase
initiale le prix de l'électricité CD
devra procurer à EDF une juste
rémunération en tenant compte de ses
coûts de production d'une rémunération
normale de son capital et des besoins
d'investissement du groupe je n'entrerai
certes pas ici dans le détail technique
mais il faut me semble-t-il dire et
insister sur ce point que ce prix doit
permettre à EDF d'investir dans de Nou
nouveau moyens de production et que
s'agissant vous voyez que nous sommes
d'accord sur certains points n'est-ce
pas alors
alors et s'agissant de la valeur de son
parc nucléaire historique une solution
raisonnable devrait pouvoir émerger
conduisant à lui conférer une valeur
significative même s'il s'agit d'un parc
déjà amorti
comptablement dernier élément sur lequel
je voudrais mettre l'accent monsieur le
ministre d'État monsieur le secrétaire
d'État et qui est propre à assurer le
succès de la réforme que vous nous
proposez c'est le caractère
incontestable de l'arbitre c'est-à-dire
celui vers lequel vont se tourner tous
les acteurs du marché et en qui ils
doivent avoir une confiance
totale
or quels que soi ses membres le gouver
gouvernement ne peut remplir ce rôle le
gouvernement est nécessairement en
conflit d'intérêt car le gouvernement
c'est le gardien c'est le protecteur des
citoyens c'est le gardien de la
compétitivité de nos
entreprise mais si c'est sa
fonction mais par ailleurs le
gouvernement c'est l'expression de
l'actionnaire majoritaire desdf et ce
sont des points de V et des
préoccupations qui sont nécessairement
un peu
contradictoires les préoccupations de
régulation générale peuvent ne pas
recouper à un moment donné les
préoccupations de l'actionnaire qui se
trouve aussi par ailleurs être un
actionnaire significatif du second
énergéticien gazde France suesse donc si
le gouvernement ne peut pas remplir ce
rôle tout naturellement
c'est au régulateur qu' incombe
c'est-à-dire à la Commission de
régulation de l'énergie et c'est parce
que je me citu dans cette logique que je
demande avec constance sans être pour le
moment entendu par la commission et par
le Gouvernement mais peu importe cela
viendra un jour je demande avec
constance que la CRE comme d'autres
régulateurs bénéficie de la personnalité
morale et de l'autonomie financière
ceci me semblerait de nature à renforcer
sa position et à améliorer encore la
perception de son
impartialité notamment du point de vue
des autorités communautaires voilà tout
ce que j'ai à dire mes chers collègues
sur les aspects généraux de la réforme
et je suis heureux d'apporter au nom de
la commission des finances mon soutien
total à la commission de l'économie et à
toutes les les remarques à tout le
travail très impressionnant qu'elle a
réalisé maintenant un mot sur l'article
12 puisque c'était l'objet de la saisine
plus particulière de notre commission
des finances nous le devons à
l'initiative toujours fertile et utile
de notre collègue député de la Marne
Charles de Courson et et il s'agite en
effet d'une réforme d'importance pour
les Collectiv
territoriale car les taxes locales sur
l'électricité représentent un produit de
l'ordre de
1,4 milliards d'euros pour les communes
les groupements de communes les
syndicats intercommunaux exerçant une
compétence d'autorité organisatrice de
la distribution d'électricité ainsi que
par les
départements là encore il s'agit de se
mettre en conformité avec le droit
communautaire et ici il s'agit d'une
directive de 2003 restructurant le cadre
communautaire de taxation des produits
énergétiques et de
l'électricité notre régime en vigueur
contrevient à plusieurs principe
figurant dans cette directive en
particulier les taxes visées par le
texte doivent être assises sur des
quantités et non sur le prix de
l'électricité consommée et elles ne
doivent pas présenter de caractère
optionnel et nous sommes déjà très en
retard et la commission a adressé à la
France le 18 mars dernier un avis motivé
ce qui est l'ultime étape avant la
saisine de la Cour de justice des
Communautés européennes il nous est donc
proposé ici de supprimer les taxes local
en
accise dont les fournisseurs
d'électricité seraient les
redevables ces accises auraiit deux
tarifs et il appartiendrait ensuite aux
collectivités bénéficiaair d'appliquer
un coefficient
multiplicateur pour
2011 une traduction automatique des taux
actuellement pratiqués par les
collectivités territoriales
bénéficiaires serait
effectué même s'il est difficile de
comparer de manière rigoureuse les
assiettes il nous a semblé que les
nouveaux tarifs retenu correspondent à
une bonne sauvegarde des recettes des
collectivités territoriale dont il
s'agit et même à une légère
majoration du rendement actuel des taxes
locales sur
l'électricité comme actuellement les
syndicats intercommunaux ou le cas
échéant les départements qui exercent la
compétence d'autorité organisatrices de
distribution d'électricité pourront se
substituer aux communes pour encaisser
la taxe cette substitution étant de
droit pour les communes de moins de 2000
habit an relevant d'un tel
syndicat pour compléter le
dispositif il est prévu et on n'a pas le
choix au plan du droit communautaire
mais finalement c'est une bonne
opportunité il est prévu au profit de
l'État une taxe intérieure sur les
consommations finales
d'électricité qui sera perçue par la
direction général des douanes et qui
s'appliquera aux consommations des
clients dont la puissance
souscrite passera 250 kV ampè
et ces entreprises n'entre pas dans le
champ des taxes locales sur
l'électricité or la directive dont je
vous disais qu'elle n'autorise plus de
système optionnel impose de taxer tout
le monde monsieur le ministre d'État
c'est une œuvre utile que vous faites
pour le budget de l'État puisque ça
représentera 65 millions d'euros en
année pleine ce n'est pas un montant
considérable mais cela mérite d'être
être salué en conclusion la réforme des
taxes locales sur
l'électricité a beaucoup évolué et dans
le bon sens par rapport à une première
tentative du gouvernement qui avait été
de l'insérer dans le collectif
budgétaire de la fin de l'année 2008 et
à ce moment-là nous n'avions pas
pu soutenir le gouvernement dans son
initiative car il s'agissait d'imposer
un taux unique sur l'ensemble du pays
sans C rendre en moyenne aux
collectivités le produit qu'elle
collectait dans le nouveau schéma les
choses sont beaucoup plus respectueuses
de l'autonomie fiscale des collectivités
territoriales elles sont même totalement
respectueuses de cette autonomie puisque
les dites collectivités garderont la
maîtrise de
le tout retrouver leur produit actuel
coup pvant escomter un produit su et il
vous a donc proposé mes chers collègues
d'adopter cet article au prix de
quelques améliorations que je
présenterai le moment venu mais
euh je voudrais insister sur le fait que
nous avons
euh souhaiter regarder de près cet
article 12 dans le contexte actuel des
finances local contexte que nous avons
évoqué depuis le début de l'après-midi
et qui conduit naturellement à ne
négliger aucune espèce de recette
n'est-ce pas dans la mesure où elle est
nécessaire pour la poursuite de nos
activités d'intérêt général merci de
votre attention merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques mzard pour le
RDSE
madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre qui est
virtuellement parmi nous mes chers
collègues je crois que oui
oui je crois que dans une discussion
générale il est normal de rappeler les
principes auxquels nous sommes attachés
s'il est en effet un domaine dans lequel
la France peut être fière de la
politique menée par deux républiques
successives c'est bien la production et
la distribution
d'électricité si aujourd'hui la France
est mise en demeure par l'Europe c'est
qu'elle a résisté à juste titre mais la
résistance à certains choix européens
est à géométrie variable selon les
dossiers le préambule de la Constitution
de 1946 disposer tout bien toute
entreprise dont l'exploitation a ou
acquierre les caractéristiques d'un
service public national ou d'un monopole
de fait doit devenir la propriété de la
collectivité le 8 avril 1946 c'était la
loi de nationalisation de 1450
entreprises qui donne naissance à EDF
établissement publics à caractère
industriel et commercial devenu un
fleuron de notre économie et de notre
pays de de l'hydroélectricité avec le
barrage de tigne en 52 jusque au
lancement en 63 de la centrale de Chinon
puis l'aventure réussie de la filière
nucléaire toute politique assumée et
partagée par la grande majorité des
français donc un appareil de production
performant exemplaire dans le monde et
une énergie électrique à un coût très
raisonnable pour nos
concitoyens pourquoi remettre en cause
ce qui fonctionnait très bien à la
satisfaction
général pour l'Europe les entreprises
d'État sont-elles un anachronisme un
frein au développement alors
qu'aujourd'hui même en Chine les
sociétés sous contrôle de l'État leur
puissance leurs Bénéfic sont le fer de
lance l'arme lourde de ce pays continent
en pleine
expansion la construction européenne à
laquelle notre groupe est très attaché
se poursuit économiquement
malheureusement autour d'un dogme d'une
obnubilation la concurrence partout pour
tout queles qu'en soient les
conséquences au nom de ce dogme
fallait-il que la France fragilise l'un
de ses plus beaux fleurons fallait-il
que la France admette un système qui
loin de préserver les tarifs
raisonnables pour les
consommateurs augure pour l'avenir et
c'est un comble au nom de la concurrence
un renchérissement du coûte de l'énergie
électrique certes monsieur le ministre
il faudra une augmentation des tarifs
mais pour financer l'allongement de la
durée de vie des centrales nucléaires et
aussi il faut le dire alléger le poids
du rachat de l'électricité
solaire nous ne doutons pas que le
projet de loi que vous nous présentez et
le travail réalisé par le rapporteur de
la commission notre collègue poniatovski
et pour objet de limiter les
conséquences néfaste pour notre filière
nationale des directives
européennes ce texte sera-t-il un
rempart suffisant malheureusement rien
n'est moins sûr comment ne pas regretter
l'incapacité de notre pays sous des
gouvernements divers et je ne me
lancerai pas dans la polémique sur la
responsabilité des uns et des autres à
peser davantage sur la rédaction des
directives européennes qui aujourd'hui
nous posent
problème celle du 19 décembre 96 puis
celle du 26 juin 2003 abrogeant la
précédente et généralisant la
concurrence dans le secteur
privé c'est sur ces bases que la
Commission européenne conteste la
compatibilité du fonctionnement actuel
du marché français avec les deux
procédures d'infraction pour défaut de
transposition de la directive 2003 et
l'autre remettant en cause les tarifs
réglementés vert et jaunes et le tarif
réglementés transitoire d'ajustement au
marché avec faut bien le dire aussi pour
couronner le tout la décision du 30
décembre 2006 du Conseil
constitutionnel le projet de loi vise
manifestement à limiter les
dégâts face au foudres de Bruxelles nous
le comprenons et nous ne doutons pas de
votre attachement à la préservation de
la filière française
de production et de distribution de
l'électricité de là à dire que nous
approuvons ce qui se réalise il y a un
large pas que ne franchira pas la grande
majorité de notre groupe cette nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
a notamment pour objet de réguler
l'accès à la production nucléaire des
fournisseurs actifs en France en mettant
en place à titre transitoire un accès
régulé et limité à l'électricité nuclé
historique l'objectif étant de permettre
aux concurrents d'EDF de disposer d'une
protection nucléaire compé d'une
production nucléaire compétitive non
d'augmenter les prix pour les
consommateurs cela n'est-il pas très
optimiste et j'ai bien écouté monsieur
le rapporteur Marini et quand même ses
inquiétudes certes la prise de session
forcé du quart de la production au
concurrents devra assurer une juste
rémunération à EDF on va vers une
régulation en amont par l'article 4 tous
les fournisseurs alternatifs pourront
concurrencer les tarif réglementés d'df
d'ici 5 ans mais au terme d'un mécanisme
complexe dont on ne discerne pas
clairement les véritables effets de la
même manière l'avenir est incertain
quant à l'évolution de la quantité
d'électricité nucléaire à céd car pour
nous il est primordial que sur le sol
national l'investissement productif
soit privilégié pour sécuriser
l'approvisionnement de la France et qui
peut mieux le faire
qu'EDF mettre entre les mains de
multinationales étrangères la capacité
de production énergétique de la France
ne serait pas
raisonnable nous sommes soucieux pour le
service public pour notre indépendance
énergétique soucieux par rapport à la
destruction des tarifs réglementés et au
risque d'augmentation des coûts pour les
usagers
et je tirerai deux
conclusions l'une positive mes chers
collègues c'est que la grande majorité
de cette hémicycle manifestement affirme
son soutien à la filière nucléaire
nationale et je me réfère d'ailleurs au
texte de la question préalable de nos
collègues socialistes et nous nous en
réjouissons la seconde qui est moins
c'est que ce débat illustre une fois de
plus que nos concitoyens ne peuvent
avoir une bonne image de la construction
européenne dans ce dédal réglementaire
pour enrober une approche qui se veut
libérale alors que nous nous considérons
que liberté que libérer doit même si
c'est difficile se conjuguer se moduler
avec des dispositifs de
régulation merci monsieur le
sénateur la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Claude d'anglot pour le groupe CRC
sppg
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en
1946 Électricité de France et Gaz de
France naissait dressés comme des
cathédrales il s'agissait en application
des décisions du Conseil National de la
Résistance de mettre sur pied deux
grands ensembles industriels au service
de la
nation cette victoire industrielle
retentissante a rendu possible une autre
victoire celle du statut national qui
s'est traduit pour les électriciens et
gaziers par une avancée sociale et
démocratique en matière de garantie
d'emploi de rémunération et de retraite
aujourd'hui le gouverneur que ce soit
avec le projet de loi nom ou celui des
retraites revient sur ces décisions
uniques qui ont marqué un tournant
décisif pour notre pays le projet de loi
nomme comme la privatisation de GDF et
la logique libérale qui guide désormais
la gestion des opérateurs historiques
pose la question de la dimension que
l'on veut donner aux politiques
industrielles et énergétiques en
particulier il y a plus de 60 ans Marcel
Paul ministre communiste défendait la
nationalisation de DF en expliquant
qu'il fallait créer les conditions d'un
équipement énergétique du pays conforme
aux besoins de la nation adapté à ses
besoins tant dans les domaines de
l'industrie que dans celui des usages
domestiques et il clamit haut et fort
devant l'Assemblée nationale
constituante il s'agit d'un problème de
vie pour le pays mes chers collègues
nous nous trouvons à un tournant crucial
et ce problème de vie se pose avec une
urgence et une actualité
édifiante comme hier il s'agit de
définir la politique énergétique de
demain de définir les nouveaux moyens de
production de garantir notre
indépendance énergétique la périnité de
nos installations et le droit d'accès à
l'énergie mais également de permettre à
notre industrie d' et nos bin d'emplois
saign à blanc par les logiques de marché
de survivre et de vivre depuis l'an 2000
le secteur énergétique a été très
gravement impacté par l'introduction de
la concurrence et de la
déréglementation les conséquences ont
été nombreuses hausse des prix de
l'énergie comme en témoigne la mise en
place du TaRTAM pour les consommateurs
non domestique implantation anarchique
des moyens de production absence de
cohérence des
investissement insuffisance des
investissements sur les réseaux de
transport et de distribution fermeture
des moyens de production de proximité et
c'est encore la concurrence qui a
justifié le découpage des entreprises en
filiale la destruction des monopoles
publics et la création d'oligopoles
privés face au défi économique et sociau
à relever le projet de loi nom porte une
atteinte sans précédente édite tant la
forme que sur le fond à la production
énergétique en s'attaquant à la
production d'origine nucléaire et en
détournant les atout qu'elle présente et
ceci dans quel but sauver nos usines
aider nos concitoyens à supporter le
coût des besoins énergétiques financer
la recherche
fondamentale évidemment non il s'agit au
nom de la concurrence en raison de
tarifs que le gouvernement juge trop bas
de favoriser les opérateurs privés sur
le marché français votre projet de loi
monsieur le ministre se départit du but
unique qui devrait guider l'action de
n'importe quel gouvernement la
satisfaction de l'intérêt général il ne
constitue pas une politique industrielle
mais un simple accord
commercial ainsi au nom de la
concurrence libre et non faussée on
impose à EDF de vendre un quart de sa
production d'énergie nucléaire on lui
impose les contrôs leur contenus leur
durée les
contractants le prix au nom de ce
principe dicté par l'Europe l'État va
garantir aux opérateurs privés des
profits au seul bénéfice de leurs
actionnaires le gouvernement brade une
part substantielle de la production des
centrales nucléaair qui ont été
construites grâce à des emprunts
souscrits par EDF garanties par l'État
et remboursé par le produit de la vente
de l'électricité cette conception de la
mission de l'État et le détournement de
ces outil industriell sont à elles seul
des raisons suffisantes pour juger que
le projet de loi Nome est
inacceptable cependant il me semble
également utile de rentrer dans le
détail du dispositif pour montrer à quel
point il serait irresponsable de
s'engager dans une telle voie le
dispositif acté à l'article 1er en suce
du holdup qu'ilorganise présente
l'inconvénient majeur d'être assez
obscur d'une part il est prévu que le
volume global d'électricité de base
pouvant être cédé ne peut excéder 100
thraw par an or monsieur Filion dans la
lettre qu'il a adressé à la commissaire
européen Nellie cross en septembre 2009
parlait déjà de ce plafond mais en le
présentant comme un plancher et il
ajouté je le cite une clause de
rendez-vous garantirant tout état de
cause l'adaptation à la hausse du niveau
du plafond si celui-ci est atteint est
atteint de manière répétée ou si la
concurrence se développait de manière
déséquilibré peut-être monsieur le
ministre pouvezvous nous donner les
indications afin que nous puissions lire
la loi à la lumière des arrangements
passés avec la commission d'autre part
en ce qui concerne l'augmentation du
plafond en raison des pertes de réseau
qui seraient de 30 TWh selon le rapport
rien est inscrit précisément dans la loi
il est renvoyé à un décret sur le prix
de cession de le flou artistique règne
nous avons entendu Henry progliot
dénoncer un pillage au-dessous de 42 €
de le MGA water monsieur borlot lui se
veut rassurant et déclaré devant les
députés je cite pourquoi donc êtes-vous
angoissé à l'idée que c'est le Parlement
de la France qui va décider de la
composition du prix de l'énergie
nucléaire la réponse est pourtant lapide
en l'état actuel la liste des éléments
qui devrai être pris en compte est
insuffisante sans que cela ne gêne la
majorité parlementaire ensuite il est
inscrit noir sur blanc que c'est la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui propose le prix enfin le problème
reste entier des conséquences de cette
vente sur la hausse des tarif la creux
l'a dit elle-même si le prix de 42 € est
retenu cela représente ésentera un coût
supérieur de 36 % au coût actuel de
l'électricité de base d'origine
nucléaire qui est donc de 30,9 €. selon
l'autorité administrative indépendante
eDF va donc naturellement relever les
tarifs bleu de 11,4 % une fois la
réforme votée puis de 3 et demi par an
entre 2011 et 2025 et l'on retrouve le
même phénomène du côté des tarifs
consentés aux entreprises d'un autre
côté un prix inférieur mettrait encore
plus en péril EDF EN BREF le dispositif
est bancal et n'est pas en mesure
d'assurer des tarifs justes dans ce
contexte si la disparition en 2015 des
tarifs verts et jaunes pour les
professionnels est acté dans le projet
de loi l'évolution de ceux appliqués au
particuliers va sérieusement les
dénaturer en bref il ressort des
articles 4 et 5 que le gouvernement
maintient sémantiquement les tarifs
réglementés mais qui n'assure plus leur
réglementation au-delà des tarifs on
constate une accélération du
désengagement de l'État qui se double
d'ailleurs d'une externalisation des
missions régaliennes attachées à la
politique énergétique le rôle accru de
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui est un des grands axes du texte la
règle selon laquelle le silence du
ministre vaut acceptation et selon
laquelle son refus doit être motivé sont
révélatrices de cette tendance la seule
et unique préoccupation est d'aligner
les tarifs de l'énergie vers le haut
afin de favoriser les distributeurs
privés à aucun moment il n est question
du financement des installations et des
réseaux à aucun moment il n'est prévu de
solutions sérieuses pour assurer le
développement des moyens de production
de demain pour favoriser l'efficacité
énergétique monsieur le rapporteur nous
contredira certainement en brandissant
l'article 2 article censé assurer la
sécurité l'approvisionnement est
constitué la contrepartie du cadeau fait
au privé contrairement à l'article 1er
cet article n'est guerre contraignant
les fournisseurs d'électricité devraient
disposer de capacité de production ou
d'effacement et ce dans un futur
incertain puisque le délai de 3 ans
incompressible ne court qu'à partir de
la publication du décret d'application
de plus il est aussitôt mentionner que
ces capacités peuvent être directes ou
indirectes permett la création d'un
marché d'échange si l'intention est
louable monsieur le rapporteur il reste
que pour assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement développer une
filière industrielle il est nécessaire
d'anticiper sur le développement des
moyens de production sur les
infrastructures nécessaires et sur les
compétences dans toutes les filières
l'article 2 est loin du compte cela
n'est guerre étonnant quand on sait que
depuis le début du processus de Li
réisation des privatisations et
d'éclatement du secteur énergétique
l'État ne s'est jamais préoccupé de
mettre en cohérence les projets des
différents groupes industriels
intervenant dans le secteur
l'anticipation n'est d'ailleurs pas le
fort du projet de loi à ce titre je
voudrais revenir sur l'article 11 qui
relèue la question du démantelllement
des centrales cette décision est très
grave cela montre que le gouvernement
est conscient qu'il porte un coup dur à
àedf et le choix est fait de faire des
économies sur les déchets nucléaires de
plus et là je ne parle pas du coût du
démentellement la loi nomme risque
d'avoir des effets néfastes sur les
capacités à investir dans le
prolongement de la durée de vie des
réacteurs après accord de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire il faudrait 600
millions d'euros par tranche soit 35
milliards s'ajoutant aux investissements
liés à la production mais aussi à toute
la chaîne qui va de la production au
consommateurs enfin sur la question du
nucléaire il est urgent que l'entreprise
publique réinternalise ses activités de
maintenance afin de répondre aux enjeux
de sûreté de garantie sociale de haut
niveau pour l'ensemble des salariés
travaillants sur le parc nucléaire il
est important de protéger de former
correctement les salariés du secteur à
ce titre nous avions demandé qu'en
conformité avec les engagements que le
gouvernement avait pris en 2004 le
statut défini à l'article 47 de la loi
de 1946 puisse s'appliquer à tous les
commercialisateurs sans dérogation ce
qui n'est pas acté par l'article 14 du
projet de loi en ce qui concerne
l'article 12 il vise à imposer aux
usagers une taxation complémentaire
obligatoire au seul motif de
l'harmonisation européenne notons
qu'accessoirement cette petite mesure
permettrait l'état de dégager des
recettes complémentaires de TVA au
milieu de tout cela quelques mesures
pourraiit être sauvée si elle n'était
pas neutralisé par le dispositif
d'ensemble l'article 1er bis relatif au
fond de solidarité pour le logement
n'apporte rien de nouveau et surtout ne
règleant rien les problèmes d'accès à ce
fond et de financement notamment avec
les conséquences financières de la
réforme des collectivités territoriales
l'extension de la contractualisation de
cap capacité d'effacement au
consommateurs raccordés au réseau de
distribution prévu à l'article 2 B est
une pierre au milieu du désert alors
qu'il faudrait bâtir une forteresse je
tiens à rappeler que l'information du
distributeur n'avait même pas été
envisagé c'est dire le cloisonnement
existant pour le gouvernement entre les
éléments de l'ancienne entreprise
intégré les articles 9 et 9 bis donc
nouveau qui étant le champ de compétence
du Médiateur national de l'énergie ne
sont pas négatif cependant l'état actuel
de la législation et au regard des
pratiques abusives de certains
opérateurs on sait bien que la
protection du consommateur n'est pas
encore suffisante j'en prendrai pour
exemple les démarchages abusifs à
domicile de commerciaux d'opérateurs
privés qui se faisaent passer pour de
faux agents de DF il y a eu des exemples
dans mon département et compris des
procès donc ont été victimes des
personnes donc dans ma région en
définitive seul l'article 10 qui
supprime l'habilitation du gouvernement
à transposer par ordonnance les
direective relative au marché intérieur
de l'énergie peut trouver grâce à nos
yeux pour conclure mes chers collègues
les sénateurs du groupe communiste et du
Parti de Gauche condamne fermement le
projet de loi de nouvelle organisation
du marché de l'électricité il s'oppose
au projet futur envisagés de
privatisation de centralees nucléaires
il constate que le gouvernement n'est
pas en capacité de mettre en œuvre une
politique industrielle qui au nom de
l'intérêt général assure les moyens de
production au niveau des besoins de la
population entière et de notre industrie
enfin juste un mot qui s'adresse plus
particulièrement à Monsieur Marini qui
assisté beaucoup beaucoup sur l'Europe
mais quand ça vous intéresse vous savez
quand même tenir tête à l'Europe même
détourner la loi communautaire à
l'exemple des Romes et quand notre
peuple se prononce clairement faut quand
même pas l'oublier par référendum contre
cette Europe libérale bah là aussi vous
savez détourner la souveraineté
nationale merci monsieur le sénateur mes
chers collègues je vais prochainement
suspendre la séance mais je donne
d'abord la parole à Monsieur le
Président de la commission de l'économie
qui l'a demandé merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues afin de faciliter la
discussion de l'article 1er du projet de
loi que nous aborderons
vraisemblablement demain je souhaiterais
que nous procédions à une discussion
séparée de l'amendement numéro 154 de
notre collègue Jean-Claude d'anglot et
des membres du groupe CRC SPG en effet
cet amendement propose une nouvelle
rédaction globale pour cet article et un
examen séparé éviterait que les 51
amendements déposés à l'article premier
soit mise en discussion commune ce qui
risquerait d'être source de confusion
pour nos débats le D à Jean-Claude
d'angloot j'ai consulté les membres du
groupe CRC c'est pour la Clif
clarification des des débats merci
madame la
Présidente il n'y a pas d'opposition à
cette proposition donc elle est adoptée
mes chers collègues nous nous retrouvons
à
21h on va dire
35 nous reprenons la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale portant nouvelle organisation
du marché de
l'électricité dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Jean-Claude
Merceron pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers
collègues la France a fait Unix chix
politique audacieux et un choix de
société en décidant de bâtir sa
politique énergétique à partir des
années 70 autour de l'électricité
nucléaire un choix visionnaire qui
permet à la France de disposer
aujourd'hui d'un parc nucléaire qui nous
est envié par de nombreuses puissances
car il couvre près de 80 % de notre
production d'électricité sans émission
de CO2 l'énergie hydraulique couvrant en
out 12 et5%
supplémentair France a vu émerger des
champions de l'industrie énergétique et
dispose aujourd'hui d'une capacité
installée supérieure à sa consommation
sauf en période de pointe certes le
traitement des déchets nucléaires reste
le talon d'achchile de cette politique
mais il faut reconnaître que nous
profitons aujourd'hui largement des
avantages que procure l'existence du
parc nucléaire historique en effet
au-delà des avantage écologique en terme
d'émission de CO2 l'électricité
nucléaire assure une une fois
l'investissement réalisé une électricité
bon marché ce faible coût est répercuté
sur les tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité française 30 % moins cher
que nos voisins européens voire 35 % de
moins qu'en Allemagne première puissance
industrielle
européenne en outre notre indépendance
énergétique à l'heure où
l'approvisionnement en matière fossile
commence à susciter des vraies luttes
géopolitiques et où les cours des
marchés sont volatiles est une force
bien sûr cet héritage qu'on appelle le
nucléaire historique n'est pas sans
limite et c'est pour cela qu'il faut se
garder de raisonner en termees
d'avantage
acquis première limite l'électricité bon
marché et en qualité aujourd'hui
suffisante n'incite que peu au
développement de nouvelles capacités de
production et au renforcement de
l'efficacité énergétique alors même que
cela paraît nécessaire pour atténuer les
effets de la hausse structurelle de la
demande les équipements des ménages
densification des réseaux de transport
électrifié entre autres
deuxièmement la situation française
n'est pas régulière au regard du droit
communautaire les tarifs réglementés qui
ont diminué de 35 à 40 % en 25 ans sont
assimilés à des aides de l'État et font
l'objet de l'IRE de la commission car il
ne permettraiit pas de couvrir le coût
réel deélectricité acheté par les
opérateurs
concurrents c'est justement cette
considération tarifaire
ainsi que la le quasi monopole d'EDF sur
les moyens de production et la
commercialisation de l'électricité qui a
déclenché l'injonction de Bruxelles de
réorganiser le marché français de
l'électricité c'est donc une
réorganisation forcée à laquelle nous
procédons aujourd'hui résultant d'un
compromis à minima àprment négocié entre
le gouvernement et la Commission
européenne spportter se limite à des
mesures transitoires qui ont vocation à
conformer le marché français de
l'électricité cité jusqu'en 2025 selon
les recommandations de la commission
chambsort dont je salue le
travail mais si ce projet de loi est une
réponse politique à priori suffisante au
regard de la commission il n'est pas
évident que le subtil l'équilibre du
projet de loi contente en cas de recours
la cour justice des Communautés
européennes plus dogmatique dans la
défense des principes de concurrence et
l'interdiction des aides assimilables à
des aides de l'État en effet
il faut
reconnaître le projet de loi Nome reste
timoré au regard du droit de la
concurrence d'une part le projet de loi
limite les avancées concurrentielles aux
seuls aspects de la vente d'électricité
qui ne représente que 7 % du prix de
l'électricité d'autre part le projet de
loi ne favorise pas dans sa rédaction
actuelle la concurrence dans la
production d'électricité par exemple en
fixant un prix de laarine en cohérence
avec le Artam on permet au mieux à
partir de 2015 d'instituer une
concurrence sur le marché des
industriels mais évidemment pas sur le
marché des particuliers or ceci
représente 86 % des sites et un/ers de
la consommation
d'électricité en outre ce sont eux qui
sont les destinataires principaux de la
politique engagée afin d'améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique domestique
comme les comportements de maîtrise de
la consommation énergétique et
stimuleront en séquence la diversité et
la qualité des offres commerciales en
fourniture
énergétique on peut penser notamment au
développement industriel d'un réseau dit
communiquant en expérimentation à tour
et à Lyon bien entendu théoriquement
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur ces
sites résidentiels existe depuis
2007 mais le ciseau tarifaire entre les
prix de marché et les tarifs réglementés
en ont fortement limité la portée en
effet seul 5 % d'entre eux ont souscrit
une offre auprès d'opérateurs
alternatifs contre 50 % en Angleterre
depuis la libération de leur marché en
ce sens le projet de loi poursuit un
objectif que nous soutenons mais de
manière trop imparfaite car il évince de
la concurrence l'activité de production
et le segment de marché des particuliers
c'est pour cette raison que nous
proposons un amendement visant à réduire
le ciseau tarifaire entre laarine et les
tarifs réglementés et à favoriser
l'investissement dans les moyens de
production pour que le projet de loi
constitue un cadre pour une concurrence
saine et
durable il faut d'ailleurs tordre le
coup à une idée reçue selon laquelle la
concurrence affaiblirait notre champion
EDF le marché de l'énergie n'est pas un
gâteau dont la multiplication des parts
réduirait d'autant leur taille le marché
de l'énergie s'envisage au-delà de nos
frontières nationales dans un cadre
communautaire et l'activité peut se
diversifier autour d'offres annexes qui
font grossir d'autant la part la part la
taille du gâteau c'est pour cette raison
d'ailleurs que nous proposerons un
amendement disposant que l'obligation de
capacité des producteurs d'électricité
doit tenir compte des interconnexion sur
le marché
européen si le mécanisme de l'arène
semble répondre à minima aux attentes de
Bruxelles il s'avère insuffisant pour
inciter les opérateurs alternatifs à
effectuer des investissements pourtant
porteur d'avenir dans les moyens de
production de base il faudrait au
contraire appliquer la citation de
Confucius quand un homme a faim mieux
vaut lui apprendre à pêcher que de lui
donner un poisson or le mécanisme de la
reine est un poisson donné aux opérateur
alternatif sa pérennité n'est pas
assurée et sa portée en terme de
concurrence durable dans la production
d'électricité n'est pas
optimale pour agir de manière durable en
faveur d'un marché concurrentiel de
l'énergie en France
il ne faudrait pas seulement céder aux
opérateurs alternatifs aprèscoutant un
certain volume d'électricité nucléaire
mais aussi leur apprendre à pêcher
c'est-à-dire les insc les inciter à
investir dans des moyens de production
propres cette vision est partagé par
plusieurs de nos collègues du groupe
centriste et nous ferons par conséquent
des propositions constructives qui
doivent permettre d'assurer un
fonctionnement optimal du marché
d'électricité d'une part en fixant le
prix de la Aren non pas en cohérence
avec le seul TaRTAM mais avec le coût de
production de l'énergie électrique telle
que comptabilisé dans la formation des
tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité l'idée est la suivante
quel que soit le prix de l'arè les prix
de revente aux consommateurs finaux
devront permettre à l'acteur historique
et aux acteurs alternatifs de dégager
une marge suffisante pour procéder aux
investissements qui assureront l'avenir
de notre politique énergétique après
en conséquence il faut faire de
l'approche transitoire proposée par le
projet de loi un levier pour le
développement de de nouvelles capacités
de puissance française de pointe mais
aussi de
base car si jusqu'en 2025 les capacités
sont suffisantes ce ne sera plus le cas
après le rapport de la commission
chambesort expose en effet qu'il serait
nécessaire de mettre en service de 700 à
1000 Gow de nouvelles centrales sur
l'ensemble de l'Europe pour remplacer
les centrales vetust et faire face à
l'accroissement au demeurant
relativement modeste de la demande
d'électricité or le temps de mise en
œuvre de ces nouveaux moyens de
production étant excessivement long
entre la décision de l'investissement la
construction et la mise en service il
est nécessaire d'anticiper
l'aprèsarène dans le présent projet de
loi outre ces considérations
concurrentielles le groupe de l'Union d
souhaite proposer d'autre part un
amendement visant à atténuer la tendance
structurelle structurellement à la
hausse des tarifs réglementés qui
devrait à terme converger vers les
tarifs de marché j'en profite pour
rappeler que ce mécanisme est structurel
et indépendant du projet de loi il faut
bien financer le coût de l'allongement
puis de renouvellement du parc nucléaire
français dans cette perspective donc le
groupe a déposé deux amendements visant
à rendre automatique le bénéfice de
tarifs particulierers pour les plus
démunis il est en effet possible d'avoir
une approche libérale de l'économie tout
en étant soucieux d'en corriger les
effets pervers auprès des populations
les plus fragiles c'est du moins dans
cet esprit que les membres de l'Union
centriste aborderont le débat enfin
notre groupe sera attentif à ce que la
Commission de régulation de l'énergie
soit un régulateur fort et indépendant
capable de fixer les prix sur la base de
considération économique et non
politique de surveiller les pratiques
concurrentielles et d'anticiper les
besoins d'investissement dans les
capacités de
production pour clore cette intervention
je souhaite simplement formuler un
souhait pour corriger une faiblesse du
projet de loi la réussite de la nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
tiendra à la visibilité que les
opérateurs industrielles pourront avoir
sur laaprè Arens or le projet de loi ne
prévoit pas de sortie progressive du
mécanisme de laarè c'est regrettable de
même la détermination d'une stratégie
claire en terme de politique énergétique
pour les 40 années prochaines sera
souhaitable afin que la politique
nucléaire ne subisse pas la même
insécurité juridique que celle que
connaît aujourd'hui la filière
photovoltaïque je vous en
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Courteau
pour le groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le Président de la Commission chers
collègues projet de loi
nomme dernier avatar d'un processus
délétaire ai-je pu lire quelque part
désormais vu l'enchaînement des épisodes
précédents la question est posé à quand
le coup de grâce pour le système
français
d'électricité un système que la France
avait construit avec succès en
1946 après avoir tiré les leçons d'un
passé confié aux compagnies privées de
l'eau et de l'éclairage ainsi alors que
dans le même temps on assiste à la
montée en puissance d'énormes intérêts
privés nombreux sont ceux qui parlent de
revanche sur 1946 6 et il est un peu
trop facile d'évoquer les exigences
européennes alors que les plus libéraux
d'entre vous prennent appui sur ces
mêmes exigences pour mieux détricoter
notre système énergétique je voudrais
ainsi rappeler à la majorité que très
très souvent elle est allée bien plus
loin que ce qu' exigeait l'Union
européenne et j'y reviendrai cela dit
dans quelle nouvelle galère nous pousse
encore le rouleau compresseur libéral
alors que partout dans le monde
ouverture à la concurrence et
libéralisation connaissent un
retentissant échec en effet pour tous
ceux qui ont cru au compte fantastique
de la fée libérale le retour sur Terre
est à mer mais alors dans quel imbroglio
cafcen nous a-ton fourré depuis 2002 et
quel monument de complexité vous nous
proposez là et dire qu'un slogan
publicitaire clairon nous vous devons
plus que la lumière et tout cela pour
aboutir à une concurrence forcée factice
artificiel c'est
ubuesque vous proposez ainsi de
contraindre EDF à céder 25 % de sa
production à la concurrence c'est le
fameux Aren accès régulé à l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire historique mais à
quel prix
EDF demande pas moins de 42 € le MW soit
le prix du TaRTAM GDF sus par exemple
revendique pas plus de 34 ou 35 € le
mgaw observez chers collègues que la
différence entre 34 € et 42 € représente
800 millions d'euros un écart d'un seul
euro en plus ou en moins de la reine se
traduit par 100 millions d'euros en plus
ou en moins pour EDF ou pour les
fournisseurs privés et comme le prix de
la reine est renvoyé à des mesures
réglementaires ce qui paraî-il donne
bien du plaisir d'ors et déjà aux
fonctionnaires du ministère nous allons
assister à une bataille sans fin au fil
des ans pour empocher cette rente
nucléaire rien n'y changera car la loi
nomme et pas nature instable mais
surtout et quoique l'on nous dise cette
loi est une loi de augmentation des prix
je m'explique à quel niveau sera fixé le
prix de l'arine peut-être au niveau de
42 € le mgaw peut-être ensuite à un
niveau plus bas or 1 € ou 2 € c'est tout
de même 100 ou 200 millions de moins
pour EDF mais dans ce cas il faudra bien
compenser EDF en autorisant par exemple
une augmentation des tarifs pour les
ménages et les petits consommateurs
d'ailleurs la mécanique infernale a déjà
été enclenchée par anticipation par
anticipation en plein 15 août jour de
l'Assomption électrique avec une
augmentation de 3 à 7,5
%. la creux a d'ailleurs annoncé que les
tarifs bleus pourraient augmenter
d'environ 11 % pour 2011 et ensuite de
3,5 % par an au final les cadeaux en
faveur des fournisseurs alternatifs
seront payés par les consommateurs
certes les tarifs réglementés seront
maintenus pour les ménages mais à terme
d'augmentation en augmentation nous
irons vers un rapprochement des tarifs
réglementés avec les prix du marché donc
vers la disparition des tarifs
réglementés mais n'est-ce pas en fait le
but recherché et c'est alors que pour
faire passer la pilule de belles
explications nous seront fournis
j'imagine qu'on nous dira surtous les
temp que l'énergie est rare dont cher et
qu'il faut investir dans de nouveaux
moyens de production donc payer
l'électricité plus cher peut-être même
nous dirat-on qu'à quelque chose malheur
est bon et que l'augmentation des prix
va obliger les consommateurs à
économiser l'électricité ce qui sera
très bon pour l'environnement je parie
que l'on osera nous dire que cette
augmentation est
vertueuse ainsi sera noyée la
responsabilité des augmentations des
prix il n'est pas sûr ce pendant que
l'on évoquera la baisse du pouvoir
d'achat des ménages l'aggravation de la
précarité énergétique ou l'atteinte
grave à la compétitivité de nos
entreprises sur ce point une remarque à
partir de 2015 votre projet supprime les
tarifs verts et jaunes tandis que
l'extinction du TaRTAM est programmé
l'étude d'impact semble nous dire pas de
problème pour les entreprises elles vont
bénéficier grâce à la reine d'une
électricité à un prix équilibré
inférieur à celui du marché or rien
n'est moins sûr par exemple aujourd'hui
dans de nombreux cas le TaRTAM couvre
toute la consommation du client mais
demain laarine devra être majoré d'abord
de la marge du fournisseur mais aussi de
la part complémentaire d'électricité que
le consommateur devra acheter au prix du
marché donc déjà le coût sera plus élevé
par ailleurs certains économistes font
remarquer qu'après la disparition des
tarifs jaunes et vert et du TaRTAM
l'arine S terraw ne couvrira pas la
totalité des besoins des industriels
estimés à plus de 232 TWh d'où un
phénomène de rareté sont les économistes
qui le disent et donc un alignement des
prix sur la bourse de gros de
l'électricité d'où des prix en forte
augmentation et déjà la SNCF annonce
devoir augmenter ses prix quelle
conséquence par ailleurs sur nos
territoirees quand on sait que le prix
de l'électricité est un facteur
important de localisation industrielle
ou de
délocalisation mais tout le monde ne
perdra pas ce jeu les gagnants seront
les fournisseurs privés qui empocheront
une partie de la rente les perdants
seront les consommateurs qui eux ne la
percevront plus bref au nom du dogme de
la concurrence on s'aborde l'un de nos
principaux avantages compétitifs les
industriels apprécieront
pour l'heure ce n'est donc pas un
concert de louange qui accompagne ce
projet de loi j'entends parler de
spoliation d'un bien commun de
patrimoine bradé de mise en concurrence
forcené de textes juridiquement fragile
d'autres comme vous monsieur le
rapporteur faut cependant remarquer que
si le nouveau système donne départ de
marché aux concurrents sans contreparti
en investissement et bien nous aurons
tout raté vous avez même fait connaître
la crainte qui était la vôre que cette
loi ne fonctionne que partiellement vous
avez même indiqué que dans ce cas vous
pourriez faire d'autres propositions
propositions qui d'ailleurs ne nous
conviennent pas davantage nous nous en
expliquerons dans la discussion des
articles mais je crois monsieur
rapporteur que il est éroné de dire que
pour fessenil catenon buget ces
centrales nucléaaires dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure il estroné de dire
qu'il y a eu ouverture du capital nous
nous en sommes entretenus il y a
quelques inst
non il n'y a pas de prise de
participation capitalistique dans ces
cas-là ce qui existe c'est que l'on
appelle c'est ce que l'on appelle des
contrats en participation ce qui n'est
pas la même chose mais alors pas du tout
mais on reviendra sur ce sujet dans le
cadre de la discussion des articles car
dans ces cas-là il n'y a aucun droit de
gouvernance ni de participation aux
décisions financières ou
industriel voilà donc où nous en sommes
chers collègues et tout cela de depuis 8
ans sur fond de melstrom législative
européen et français et tout cela
d'ailleurs sur fond de promesses non
tenu souvenez-vous je cite il n'y aura
pas de privatisation de DF et de GDF
c'est clair c'est simple et c'est net
avait dit le ministre des Finances
monsieur Sarkozi à Chinon avant
d'ajouter je veux décliner cette valeur
que sont la confiance dans la parole
donnée et le respect et il ajouté je
n'ai pas envie de mentir au français
je pense que cela fait trop longtemps
que le débat politique souffre d'un
manque d'authenticité et d'honnêteté fin
de citation 2 ans après GDF GDF était
privatisé et une fois de plus vous êtes
allés vous mesdames et messieurs de la
majorité plus loin que ce qu'exigeait
l'Europe et le rouleau compresseur
libéral a continué d'avancer alors que
partout dans le monde l'augmentation des
prix la Pan de l'investissement sont au
haut rendez-vous vous de la
libéralisation et de l'ouverture à la
concurrence partout les prix ont flambé
plus 49 % en Allemagne plus
1 % au Royaume-Uni plus 92 % au Danemark
pour la France dès l'ouverture du marché
de ha gros consommateur même musique à
tel point qu'il fallut inventer je sais
que vous êtes pour quelque chose le
fameux TaRTAM ailleurs dans le monde on
a fait marche arrière en Europe et en
France on persiste
la recherche de la concurrence le fameux
dogme de la concurrence est toujours une
fin en soi à tel point que faute de
pouvoir la faire émerger y compris au
forceps dans un secteur comme celui de
l'énergie secteur pourtant incompatible
avec les mécanismes concurrentiels il
vous faut aujourd'hui la créer
artificiellement quitte à casser ce qui
a fonctionné parfaitement bien pendant
plus de 50 ans toujours ce trouble
obsessionnel de la concurrence
le fameux toc qu' a cité mon collègue
daniel Raoul éminent spécialiste partout
dans le monde on constate l'échec patant
de la libéralisation et pourtant on
persiste à faire confiance dans la main
invisible du marché comme un moyen de
réguler il semblerait même que la
doctrine soit la suivante si le
libéralisme ne marche pas c'est parce
qu'il n'y a pas assez de libéralisme et
donc on s'enfonce plus encore mais mes
chers collègues de la majorité quand on
arrive au fond du trou il faut
impérativement arrêter de creuser
observez ce qui se passe dans le monde
ceux qui étaient les pionniers de la
libéralisation tousazimut semblent avoir
enfin compris qu'il est temps de faire
marche arrière alors que reproche-t-on à
la France d'avoir des prix trop bas en
clair on nous reproche d'avoir réussi à
bâtir un modèle à part cité un exemple
dans le monde entier bref un vrai crime
de laise concurrence et pour nous
récompenser d'avoir pris des risques
financiers et industriels on nous
demande aujourd'hui au nom de la
sacrinte concurrence de brader nos
productions et notre patrimoine commun
on nous demande d'amputer EDF d'une
partie de sa production céder à prix
coûtant aux opérateurs privés bel
exemple de concurrence
artificielle étrange exemple de
concurrence non
faussé bel exemple oui bel exemple de
concurrence artificielle en fait on
demande d'une certaine manière au
secteur public juger trop performant
peut-être de subventionner la
concurrence qui elle ne l'est pas assez
on marche suis la tête disait Marcel
Boiteux
oui quand les bornes sont franchies il
n'y a plus de limite je voudrais bien
que l'on m'explique où est dans tout
cela l'intérêt général du pays je
rappellerai aussi que la final de la
création du marché européen était
l'intérêt des consommateurs je vois que
monsieur jacqublanc est arrivé or ceci
sont aujourd'hui les grands laissés pour
compte par ailleurs n'oublions jamais
que l'acceptation du nucléaire pour les
français passe par une politique
tarifaire juste et par le maintien dans
un pôle public de notre appareil de
production garde-nous d'oublier que
l'électricité est un bien indispensable
non stockable de première nécessité et
non une simple marchandise gardonsnous
d'oublier que la précarité énergétique
est un mal qui est en train de toujours
plus progresser gardons-nous d'oublier
qu'après avoir été un vecteur de
correction des inégalités sociales et
territoriales le secteur de l'énergie ne
doit pas contribuer au creusement des
inégalités se chauffer aujourd'hui
représente 15 % du budget d'un ménage
modeste contre 6 % pour les catégories
aisé et demain et demain Monsieur
Jacques Blanc arrêtons les frais
aujourd'hui le problème n'est plus de
faire baisser les prix mais d'accepter
ou non de les laisser monter pour
s'aligner progressivement sur ceux du
marché beau résultat que voilà où est
là-dedans l'intérêt du consommateur on
nous avait dit qu'il fallait ouvrir
l'électricité à la concurrence pour
faire baisser les prix et voilà
qu'aujourd'hui il faut les augmenter
pour permettre la concurrence oui on
marche sur la tête pour qu les
fondements d'une alternative existe
prenons l'article 90 du traité devenu
article 106 de la nouvelle version du
traité sur le fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne qui stipule notamment que les
entreprises chargées de la gestion des
services d'intérêt économique général ou
présentant le caractère de monopole
fiscal sont soumises aux règles des
traités notamment aux règles de
concurrence dans les limites dans les
limites ou l'application de ces règles
ne fait pas échec à l'accomplissement en
droit ou en fait de la mission
particulière qui leur est impartie on
peut affirmer ici que le service de
l'électricité ne relève pas de cette
mission particulière qui peut
l'affirmer voilà une voix que l'on
aurait dû emprunter afin d'exclure des
règles strictes de la concurrence
certains services publics d'intérêt
général comme celui de l'énergie je
rappelle que lors du Conseil énergie de
septembre de cette même année plusieurs
ministres de plusieurs états-membes ont
reconnu que la concurrence ne faisait
pas baisser les prix les choses bougent
les choses commencent à évoluer de plus
pourquoi n'avoir jamais soutenu ce que
les groupes socialistes ont toujours
demandé c'est-à-dire l'adoption d'une
directive cadre sur les services publics
d'intérêt général pour justement écarter
le secteur énergétique des règles de
concurrence ce projet de directive cadre
est toujours réalisable d'ailleurs le
groupe socialiste du Parlement européen
a déposé une proposition de directive
dois-je une fois de plus rappeler quitte
à me répéter que Lionel Jospin avait
obtenu lors du sommet de Barcelone en
mars 2002 avec Monsieur Chirac que soit
inscrit dans les conclusions le principe
d'une directive cadre sur les services
d'intérêt économique général pourquoi
les différents gouvernements de droite
qui se sont mis en place depuis 2002
n'ont-ils jamais cherché à infléchir
l'approche de l'Union européenne dans un
secteur aussi stratégique que celui de
l'énergie en vérité tout cela vous
convenez très bien en effet c'est bien
le gouvernement Jupé qui en 96 a signé
la première directive ouvrant aux
industriels le marché de l'énergie et
c'est bien le gouvernement de Monsieur
rafarin qui le 25 novembre 2002 a
accepté l'ouverture totale du marché
faisant sauter ainsi le verrou posé par
le gouvernement Jospin à Barcelone en
fait il y eu plusieurs lois transposé an
les directives en 2000 2003 2004 2006 oh
je sais on va me dire mais en 2000
c'était un gouvernement de gauche qui
était au commande effectivement je vous
rappelle que la directive a été
transposée à minima et en mettant tous
les moyens en place pour préserver le
service public de l'électricité et
j'entends encore les cris d'indignation
de sénateurs ou de députés de l'époque
de droite par exemple notre collègue
ex-collègue Revol rapporteur sur ce
texte qui n'a eu de cesse de dénoncer le
choix du gouvernement jospen d'effectuer
je cite une transposition tardive et
insuffisamment libéral il regrettait que
la France choisisse de limiter le degré
d'ouverture au minimum pour les
professionnels par exemple l'Assemblée
nationale monsieur Borotra ancien
ministre qui fièrement s'exclama le
projet de loi que vous nous présentez et
la transcription à votre façon d'une
directive que j'ai eu l'honneur de
négocier au nom du gouvernement et il
ajouta votre projet de loi est un
parcours d'obstacle pour limiter
l'exercice de la concurrence et vier
l'essentiel de son contenu la
libéralisation du marché voilà qui est
clair et combien de parlementaires de
droite à l'époque s'étaiit réjoui en
novembre 2002 lorsque la ministre Nicole
Fontaine accepta l'ouverture totale du
marché à la concurrence je me souviens
alors que l'on se congratuler à droite
on se félicitait même de ce compromis
qui n'était autre en fait qu'une
capitulation la suite on la connaît et
il a bien fallu déchanter depuis
d'ailleurs on narrête pas de légiférer
de rapisser d'administrer des soins
palliatifs combien de textes depuis 2008
9 10 et combien d'autres après la nomeme
et pour nous convaincre qu'avec la nomme
nous allons entrer dans un monde
merveilleux l'étude de l'impact l'étude
d'impact pardon du gouvernement qui est
aveuglément optimiste tente de nous
faire croire que tout le monde sera
gagnant un monde merveilleux vous dis-je
avec plus de de visibilité plus
d'incitations à investir plus de
garantiese pour les consommateurs unique
bénéficiaire de bas cou de l'électricité
et bien évidemment aucun effet domain la
réalité hélas ne sera pas si édélique
que ça concernant par exemple la
visibilité annoncée par l'étude d'impact
à y regarder de plus près nous serions
plutôt dans le brouillard des
incertitude mais nous y reviendrons plus
tard en fait l'expérience nous montre
que plus un positif et complexe plus il
conduit à un grand nombre de changements
donc à une moindre visibilité toute
chose nuisible à l'économie quel sera
ensuite l'effet nom sur les
investissements négatif affirment
certains économistes l'étude d'impact se
contente d'affirmer sans le démontrer
que la nomme indindua des incitations
appropriées nous sommes peut-être
éblouis mais nous ne sommes pas éclairés
pour autant de plus de façon surprenante
la NME qui se présente comme un
dispositif transitoire ne prévoit aucun
mécanisme de sortie crédible de la
régulation à l'instar par exemple d'une
décroissance progressive et échelonné
des volumes de l'arine céd aux
alternatifs à l'exception d'un éventuel
d'un éventuel rapport qui en 2015
pourrait se pencher sur ce problème vous
ne prévoyez même pas leur sevrage ils
voudront donc conserver le biberon le
plus longtemps possible mais alors quel
intérêt auront-ils à investir et EDF
sera-t-elle incitée à investir si
supportant 100 % des risques elle doit
céder une partie des bénéfices à ses
concurrents dès lors notre système
électrique ne va-t-il pas connaître des
défaillances je vais m'apprêter à
conclure Madame la
Présidente un autre problème cependant
que je voudrais soulever ce texte
pourrait bien être aussi une source
d'insécurité juridique au niveau
européen il s'agit de de la question de
la portée de la clause de destination
qui figure à l'article 1er même si d'cun
ne veulent le reconnaître cette
disposition résistera-t-elle au foudre
de Bruxelles je ne le crois pas l'accord
Fillon cross ne sera pas suffisant si
plainte est déposée par un client
résidant dans un autre État membre pour
restriction incompatibles avec les
règles du marché intérieur notez qu'il y
a le précédent GDF et Eon mais je
reviendrai sur ce point plus tard et je
conclus voilà donc un projet de loi
d'une grande complexité d'où de nombreux
réajustements en perspective à tel point
que je me demande si en raison de
nombreuses incertitudes vous n'allez pas
nous proposer sous peu monsieur les
ministres une nouvelle loi destinée à
corriger celle-ci et puis une autre
encore qui corrigera la précédente et
ainsi de suite nous allons donc proposer
un certain nombre d'amendements de
suppression par voie d'amendement nous
proposerons également notre voie que
celle de la libéralisation totale du
marché de l'énergie en effet qu'est-ce
qui prime le plus l'intérêt des
consommateurs français ou celui des
opérateurs privés au nom de la sacrointe
concurrence bref nous essons chers
collègues de vous convaincre de nos
position tout au long de ces débats mais
comme l'affirmaé un parlementaire une
panne d'électricité laisse l'aveugle
indifférent et j'ai bien peur qu'il en
soit de même pour le gouvernement mais
si vous chers collègues adopter ce texte
tel quel alure alors ne l'appelez plus
jamais nom mais baptisez-le d'homme
comme désorganisation du marché de
l'électricité merci
Monsieur la parole est à Monsieur Benoît
Huré pour
l'UMP
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues ce projet de loi portant
nouvelle organisation du marché de
l'électricité un objectif clair assurer
à chaque consommateur des prix de
l'électricité
compétitif représentatif des coûts de
production du parc français quel que
soit le choix du
fournisseur chaque fournisseur
alternatif pouvant approvisionner ses
clients en France à partir d'électricité
acquise auprès de DF au coût complet du
parc nucléaire
historique l'équilibre entre droit et
devoir des fournisseurs est ainsi trouvé
les fournisseurs alternatifs ont un
droit à acquérir de l'électricité auprès
de DF ce dernier a un devoir de vendre
de l'électricité au fournisseurs
alternatifs à un prix couvrant les coûts
complets les fournisseurs alternatifs
ont un devoir de contribuer à la
sécurité
d'approvisionnement ce qui entraîne une
mutualisation de cette charge
aujourd'hui assumée par EDF
uniquement ce texte est à la fois
important ce texte est aussi
indispensable
important car il conserve les avantages
du système actuellement en vigueur tout
en corrigeant les imperfections il place
ainsi notre pays sur la voie d'une
organisation pérenne novatrice et
conforme aux enjeux d'avenir
indispensable parce que l'organisation
actuelle du marché de l'électricité en
France n'est pas satisfaisante et qu'il
fallait au risque d'un conflit ouvert
avec les autorités européennes trouver
un nouvel équilibre en refondant la
régulation du secteur il s'agit de
protéger les consommateurs qui
continueront à bénéficier de prix de
vente de l'électricité fonder sur les
coûts du nucléaire mais aussi peut-être
et surtout il s'agit d'offrir un cadre
stable et propice à l'investissement
parce que le cœur du débat qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui c'est le financement
des investissement nécessairire pour la
production d'électricité le nucléaire
bien entendu mais également la pointe
qui est l'un des sujets majeurs auquels
nous sommes aujourd'hui
confrontés à ce sujet d'ailleurs je
tiens à insister sur le remarquable
rapport effectué par le groupe de
travail coprésidé par nos collègues
Bruno sidau et cherge poignant sur la
maîtrise de la pointe
électrique le contexte européen est
également une des raisons d'un
changement nécessaire actuellement la
concurrence en Europe n'est pas très
développée pire notre pays est menacé
par un contentieux avec la Commission de
Bruxelles au sujet du fameux dispositif
TaRTAM et des tarifs réglementés pour
les moyens et grandes entreprises avec
un risque non négligeable pour nos
entreprises de devoir rembourser des
milliards d'euros la suspicion d'aide
d'État en faveur des consommateurs
existe bel et bien nous ne pouvons pas
être les mauvais élèves de l'Europe et
il est important de réagir à ce
contentieux pour aide d'État s'ajoute un
deuxè contentieux avec Bruxelles pour
non transposition de la directive de
2003 avec une sévère
de l'existence des tarifs
réglementés cela nous expose à une
condamnation par la Cour de justice des
Communautés européennes à des astreintes
et à l'extinction des tarifs réglementés
l'enjeu n'est pas mince je sais Monsieur
le Ministre que le gouvernement récuse
les grillèves de la la commission mais
le risque est réel et je crois qu'il ne
vaut vraiment pas la peine d'être couru
aujourd'hui nul ne peut contester qu'une
réforme du marché est absolument
nécessaire nous savons que la Commission
renoncera au contentieux si la nouvelle
organisation du marché l'électricité est
mise en place dans les plus brefs délais
je vous rappelle mes chers collègues que
la Commission européenne a ses propres
solutions le démantèlement pur et simple
de DF et la suppression de toute forme
de
régulation la solution du gouvernement
est la seule voie de passage équilibrée
qui s'inscrit dans le européen de
l'électricité pour assurer sa pérennité
le projet de loi nom doit donc être
compatible avec l'ouverture des marchés
en Europe et ainsi donner à tous les
acteurs la possibilité de faire des
propositions innovantes de service
d'économie d'énergie aujourd'hui seul
EDF peut y parvenir les autres acteurs
étant étranglés par leur coût
d'approvisionnement il fallait donc
assurer aux concurrents de DF le moyen
de servir leurs clients dans des
conditions de prix comparable à celle de
DF comme je le disais en début de mon
propos en dehors des critiques de
Bruxelles l'organisation actuelle du
marché de l'électricité n'est pas
satisfaisante elle est très complexe et
peu lisible les consommateurs se
retrouve cloisonné dans des catégories
hermétiques et quelquefois incohérentes
elle est instable et n'a pas abouti car
fondé sur des dispositifs
transitoires ainsi l'organisation
actuelle du marché de l'électricité
ne permet pas d'assurer la prévisibilité
absolument majeure en matière
d'investissement le rapport champsort
est à ce sujet très clair et je ne
reviendrai pas sur son contenu je salue
le remarquable travail effectué par la
commission Schor où siéger plusieurs
parlementaires dont notre rapporteur
Ladislas patowski il a abouti à une
proposition très claire pour sortir de
l'impasse dans laquelle nous nous
trouvions dans son projet de loi le
gouvernement a choisi de suivre les
recommandations
assez consensuelle d'ailleurs au niveau
national de la commission
sanschor la solution consiste à obliger
EDF l'opérateur historique à céder au
fournisseurs alternatifs une partie de
sa production d'origine nucléaire à
hauteur de 100 tawur soit environ 25 %
de cette production et ce au prix
coûtant de façon à développer la
concurrence mais aussi à préserver
l'avantage que les Français peuvent et
doivent tirer de l'existence du
nucléaire qui est un élément important
de la compétitivité de nos entreprises
le dispositif proposé réalise trois
objectifs majeurs assurer la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
sécuriser les approvisionnements et
permettre à la concurrence d'exister
pour cela différents mécanismes ont été
prévus sur lesquels je ne reviendrai pas
notre rapporteur ayant parfaitement
expliqué le système mise en mise en
place je note simplement que le prix de
cette cet accès à l'électricité
nucléaire historique ne sera pas un prix
bradé comme on peut l'entendre ici ou là
mais un prix complet couvrant toutes les
charges réelles du parc nucléaire
historique deedf il n'y a donc aucun
holdup ni spoliation deedf il faut
simplement que ce prix ne soit pas
instable qu'il ne fluctue pas et qu'il
assure à EDF une situation financière
saine par ailleurs le projet de loi
inscrit la nécessité d'investir dans le
parc électrique par la mise en place
d'une obligation de capacité de
production pour les fournisseurs cela
est avantageux pour EDF qui ne sera plus
seul à assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement l'incitation à
l'investissement et donc au centre de ce
texte c'est la situation actuelle qui
est peu favorable à l'investissement un
autre point important est le maintien au
profit des particuliers du tarif régulé
sans date cela permet de dire aux
consommateurs que s'ils le souhaitent
ils peuvent bénéficier d'un accès à
l'électricité selon un tarif fixé par
les pouvoirs publics en fait par le
pouvoir politique sur proposition du
régulateur la Commission de régulation
de l'énergie en outre le système de
tarifs pour les entreprises disparaîtra
progressivement jusqu'en 2015 à cette
date il ne pourra plus y avoir de tarifs
pour les entreprises seules les
particuliers conserveront le bénéfice
des tarifs régulés qui sont donc
confortés et pérennisés on ne peut donc
pas dire que la régulation est supprimée
le texte prévoit davantage de régulation
là où il en avait si peu la loi du 10
février 2000 proposé par le gouvernement
socialiste de l'époque a ouvert le
marché de l'électricité aux grandes
entreprises sans précaution et sans
garde fou notre majorité a commencé dès
2002 à corriger les effets néfastes de
cette ouverture débridée pour abourtir
aujourd'hui à ce texte qui régule les
prix de gros les prix à la sortie de
production ce projet de loi a fait le
choix d'une régulation différente mais
toujours forte du marché de
l'électricité c'est l'essentiel à nos
yeux on entend ici ou là qu'il pourrait
y avoir des augmentations de tarifs ce
n'est évidemment pas le cas ça n'a aucun
rapport il faut le dire très clairement
ce texte ne traite pas du niveau du des
tarif deélectricité il organise les
rapports entre fournisseurs
d'électricité le prix de notre énergie
est en moyenne de 30 % inférieur à la
moyenne européenne il faut maintenir
pour les consommateurs et les
industriels cet avantage les tarifs
réglementés pour les petits
consommateurs sont maintenus et le prix
payé par le consommateur final reflète
strictement la charge du système
électrique français et leur évolution
par ailleurs la concurrence sera
favorisée au profit du consommateur
notamment en matière d'innovation avant
de conclure monsieur le ministre je
souhaite au nom du groupe UMP vous dire
notre conviction en matière d'énergie
nucléaire elle n'est pas sans rapport
avec le projet de loi que nous allons
examiner nous sommes convaincu qu'il
faut assurer l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire française celle-ci est un
élément stratégique de la politique
énergétique industrielle de la France le
rapport rousseli a fait des propositions
très importantes et B et dans le camp du
gouvernement des décisions ont déjà été
prises mais nous pensons qu'il faut
aller plus loin pour conforter et
pérenniser l'industrie nucléaire dans
notre pays c'est un enjeu national de
première ampleur que seul l'état peut
poursuivre avec succès mes chers
collègues nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités avec ce texte nous avons
relevé un premier défi parvenir à un
équilibre entre la protection du
consommateur français qui continuera à
bénéficier des avantages que lui apporte
l'électricité nucléaire et l'ouverture
du marché réclamé par Bruxelles est
nécessaire pour assurer une saine
concurrence ce cadre législatif lisible
et cohérente doit assurer le financement
des lourds investissements qui nous
attendent d'autres défis nous attendent
je l'ai dit notamment l'avenir du
nucléaire civil tel est l'enjeu de ce
texte auquel le groupe UMP apportera
tout son
soutien
merci la parole est au président
pour le
RDSE madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président et
Maine mes chers
collègues l'énergie est probablement
l'un des défis majeurs auquel sera
confronté l'ensemble des pays lors de la
prochaine décennie pourtant la politique
énergétique européenne est encore à
construire aujourd'hui elle repose avant
tout comme beaucoup de matière sur le
recours à la concurrence afin d'éviter
la constitution ou le maintien de
monopole en cassant les chaînes
intégrées du producteur au consommateur
final cette politique européenne en
gestation cherche finalement à
construire artificiellement des marché
où les prix pourraient se former
librement sur le modèle du pétrole
malheureusement cela ne fonctionne
rarement c'est que c'est ainsi que
plusieurs États fédérés américains ont
entrepris en retour sur la
libéralisation de leur secteur
énergétique en s'appuyant pour cela sur
le modèle français plus proche de nous
en Grande-Bretagne l'autorité
régulatrice a fait elle aussi part de
son inquiétude quant aux conséquences de
la libéralisation sur les
investissements de long terme la
sécurité des approvisionnements et
l'efficacité énergétique en effet deux
ruptures sont venus modifier le cadre de
référence de la politique de
libéralisation d'abord la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique qui s'est
progressivement affirmé comme une
priorité politique ensuite la sécurité
des approvisionnements énergétiques
européens en effet la nécessité
d'intégrer ces nouveaux élément conduit
à poser frontalement la question de la
cohérence de la politique énergétique
européenne qui fait face en des enjeux
mais aussi à des attentes de nature
plutôt
hétérogène nous savons tous ici que
grâce au développement progressif des
secteurs de l'hydroélectrique et de
l'industrie
électronucléaire la France dispose de
l'électricité la moins chère d'Europe
l'enjeu du texte sur lequel nous devons
nous prononcer est de savoir si la
nouvelle organisation permettra à notre
pays de maintenir une électricité bon
marché dans un contexte de concurrence
effffrainé et d'impératif écologique
monsieur le ministre vous répondez oui
nous verrons est-il légitime de remettre
en cause aujourd'hui l'avantage
énergétique français unique au monde
pour permettre à des opérateurs privés
incapables d'offrir un meilleur prix
d'exister sur le marché français de
l'électricité je pose la question cette
manière d'ouvrir le marché est pour le
moins bizarre puisqu'elle consiste à
créer une distorsion de concurrence au
détriment de l'entreprise mieux disante
EDF et donc par voie de conséquence à
notre détriment on peut aisément
imaginer les conséquences du projet de
loi dans sa mouture actuelle alignement
progressif des tarifs réglementés sur
les standards européens 30 à 50% plus
cher maintenance des réseaux
fragilisés difficulté de financement du
parc électronucléaire et cetera et
cetera bref avec l'abandon d'une
certaine idée du service public nos
concitoyens monsieur le ministre ne
risque-t-il pas d'être sacrifié sur
l'Hôtel De La pas du gain de société
bien plus préoccupé par la course au
bénéfice que par l'intérêt général là
aussi je pose la question quoi qu'il en
soit les Français seront seuls juges
devant leur facture d'électricité et ce
dans les prochaines années en
choisissant la libéralisation complète
des prix ainsi que la mise en place d'un
accès régulé à l'existtrit de base avec
une la disparition progressive des
tarifs réglementés pour les industriels
le gouvernement n'ouvre-t-il pas ainsi
la voie à l'augmentation du coût
deélectricité pour tous sans pour autant
régler les vrais enjeux auxquels doit
faire face le secteur de l'énergie en
France autre question or le premier
enjeu est bien la valorisation de notre
expertise nucléaire dans le monde par un
meilleur ordonnancement des acteurs du
secteur un investissement indispensable
dans la maintenance de nos centrales
nucléaires mais aussi la formation des
hommes et des femmes pour en assurer une
meilleure disponibilité et aussi une
sécurité optimale ses capital qui aurait
cru que même aux États-Unis le
trèsfervant gouverneur libéral de
Californie ramènerait progressivement
dans le secteur public la gestion du
parc nucléaire
californien le second enjeu est la
diversification indisp ble de notre
bouquet énergétique associé à la
recherche à l'innovation et à la
construction de filières industrielles
et de filières de services créatrices
d'emploi ce sont les grandes grandes
absentes de ce projet de loi qui ne
comportent notamment aucune mesure
significative sur le parc hydraulique et
sur les investissements à consentir pour
en accroître la productivité en réalité
monsieur le ministre il s'agit d'un
texte qui repose d'abord ça a été dit et
redit sur un dogme qui nous semble
dépasser dans le contexte actuel le
dogme libéral de l'ouverture à la
concurrence à tout prix quels qu'en
soient les conséquences sur l'emploi
l'environnement la sécurité lié au Procé
industriel aussi ce texte affecte-t-il
en premier lieu la filière énergétique
elle-même et ce en dép en dépit d'une
expertise qui est le fruit de dizaines
d'années d'investissement public dans la
formation la recherche
l'industrie en conclusion avec les
membres de mon groupe dans sa diversité
bien connue nous serons attentifs aux
travaux de la Haute Assemblée en Science
Publique mais en l'état pour la grande
majorité d'entre nous il nous est pas
possible d'apporter monsieur le ministre
notre soutien à ce texte je vous
remercie
parfait
parfait la parole est à Monsieur Xavier
Pinta pour
l'UMP
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers
collègues le processus d'adaptation de
notre système électrique s'avère
décidément bien complexe après avoir
légiféré en 2000 2003 2004 2005 et 2006
pour respecter le choix d'une ouverture
progressive et maîtrisée du marché
énergétique français est achevé
d'ailleurs le 1er juillet 2007 bien nous
sommes une fois encore conduit à
débattre de cette
question le problème de fond auquel ce
texte s''estorce de répondre et celui de
la difficulté que nous rencontrons à
ouvrir effectivement la la fourniture
d'électricité à la concurrence alors que
nos engagements européens nous en font
l'obligation il est toutefois
fondamental de veiller à ce que cette
évolution ne contrevienne pas aux
intérêts des consommateurs d'énergie tel
est bien monsieur le ministre le
challenge que le gouvernement choisi de
relever avec ce projet de loi dont l'un
des objectifs majeurs est de continuer à
faire bénéficier ces consommateurs de la
compétitivité du parc de production
électrique en France notamment nucléaire
la réussite de cette démarche repose en
grande partie sur la loyauté attendue
des fournisseurs d'électricité
bénéficiire du nouveau dispositif
d'accès régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique
laarinene nous nous apprêtons en effet
par ce texte à supprimer à compté du 1er
janvier 2016 le bénéfice des tarifs
réglementés de vente pour tous les sites
ayant souscrit une puissance supérieure
à 3 kva c'est une concepction
d'importance pour nos compatriotes
attaché vous le savez à ces tarif qui
avait fait depuis plus d'un demi-siècle
la preuve de leur efficacité économique
et sociale tel qu'il est actuellement
rédigé ce texte peut même apparaître
comme plus restrictif du point de vue du
périmètre des tarifs réglementé par
rapport à la directive européenne du 13
juillet 2009 celle-ci prévoit un fait le
droit au service universel pour les
consommateurs domestiques mais aussi
pour les PME jusqu'à 50 salariés 10
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
alors même que celle-ci aurait souscrit
des puissances importantes l'amendement
que je vous avais proposé sur ce point
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur n'a pas été retenu par la
commission il est vrai que
l'articulation entre l'approche en terme
de puissance souscrite qui caractérise
nos barêmes tarifaires et une approche
en terme de taille entreprise serait
techniquement
délicate je reste néanmoins convaincu
que l'avantage compétitif qu'offre ces
tarifs est devenu vital pour nos PME PMI
il favorise la localisation de nos
entreprises sur notre territoire si
cette difficulté technique ne pouvait
être levée il me paraît en contrepartie
impératif de veiller à ce que la
garantie de marge commerciale octroyée
aux fournisseurs bénéficiaires de la
Renn et comme condition une stricte
interdiction de tout abus de ce droit
d'accès régulé il est également
essentiel que les fournisseurs concernés
concourent effectivement à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en électricité sous
la forme des capacités d'effacement de
consommation et de production d'énergie
que le projet de loi prévoit de leur
imposer bien sûr il faut pas perdre de
vue que les travaux de notre commission
ajoutés à ceux de nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale ont d'ors et déjà
permis d'améliorer significativement ce
texte dans le sens de nos préoccupations
je souhaite vivement remercier nos
collègues de la commission des affaires
économiques présidé par Jean-Paul
etemourine au premier rang desquels bien
sûr notre rapporteur Ladislas katowski
réputé pour son sens de l'écoute et la
qualité de son expertise dans le domaine
de l'énergie il me semble néanmoins que
des améliorations soient encore
possibles s'agissant notamment de la
situation particulière des des
entreprises locales de distribution et
des consommateurs
domestiques je rappelle que durant un
demi-siècle les principaux éléments de
diversité au sein du système électrique
français ont été les distributeurs non
nationalisés en 1946 c'est-à-dire les
régies les sociétés d'économie mixte
local ou encore certains distributeurs
de statut coopératifs qui représentent
actuellement environ 5 % de la
distribution d'électricité ça a été
rappelé ces opérateurs le plus souvent
petite taille accomplissent depuis des
décennies leur mission dans un dans le
cadre de service public dans un cadre de
service public qui donne pleinement
satisfaction dans l'immense majorité des
cas leurs territoires auront bénéficié
d'une qualité d'énergie et de service
irréprochable de manière paradoxal la
rédaction actuelle du projet de loi qui
promut la pluralité des opérateurs
électriques remet simultanément en cause
certains éléments importants de
l'équilibre économique de ces opérateurs
historiques par exemple il supprime à
compté du 1er janvier 2014 le bénéfice
du tarif de cession pour les achats
d'électricité correspondant aux pertes
je crois qu'il faut y être attentif et
peut-être revoir certains arbitrages
dans ce domaine en ce qui concerne les
consommateurs domestique il est observé
que le nombre de bénéficiaires effectifs
des tarifs sociaux de l'énergie
c'est-à-dire je le rappelle le tarif de
première nécessité pour l'électricité et
le tarif spécial de solidarité pour le
gaz et bien le nombre de bénéficiaires
est faible par rapport au nombre de
personnes qui pourrai y prétendre à
savoir toutes celles et ceux qui entrent
dans le dispositif de la couverture de
malades universelle il semble que cet
écart provienne largement de
l'obligation pour les personnes
concernées de formuler expressément leur
demande d'attribution du tarif social ce
qu'il faut bien avouer n'est pas
toujours aisé contenu des populations
visées et des difficultés auxquelles
elles le sont confrontés certains de ces
ces dysfonctionnements ont d'ailleurs
été identifiés par le médiateur national
de l'énergie évoqué récemment dans
l'actualité de nombreux acteurs de
l'énergie considèrent qu'il est dans ces
conditions préférable de prévoir une
attribution automatique du bénéfice des
tarifs sociaux au bénéficiaaires de la
CMU cela économiserait des coûts
administratifs et permettrait à ce
dispositif je crois de fonctionner de
manière plus satisfaisante pour terminer
mon propos un mot prise sur l'initiative
prise de procéder enfin la transposition
dans le domaine de la taxe sur
l'électricité de la directive européenne
de 2003 sur la fiscalité de l'énergie je
voudrais là aussi monsieur le ministre
vous exprimer mes plus vifs
remerciements pour l'esprit de
coopération dans lequel sur ce dossier
les services ministériels ont mené la
concertation avec les collectivités
locales et en particulier avec les
autorités organisatrices de la
distribution d'électricité la rédaction
adoptée par notre commission sur
proposition de notre rapporteur me
paraît pour l'essentiel bien répondre
aux importants enjeux qui s'attache à ce
dispositif qui concerne je le rappelle
le financement d'une grande partie des
travaux d'électrification en milieu
rurale c'est pourquoi il convient de
rester attentif à ce que le niveau de
cette ressource fiscale soit maintenu
malgré des objectifs très légitimes
d'ailleurs de diminution de la
consommation d'énergie j'ai proposé un
amendement en ce sens enfin bien que
l'objet principal de ce projet de loi
concerne la production et la
commercialisation de l'énergie
électrique certaines questions
afférentes à la distribution
d'électricité y ont également été
insérés en particulier en matière de
financement des raccordements des
producteurs
d'électricité il me semblerait opportun
de profiter de cette circonstance pour
apporter une précision sur le rôle des
auto ité organisatrices des services
publics d'électricité dans ce domaine
particulier ainsi que plus généralement
sur les information que les
gestionnaires de réseau doivent leur
fournir dans le cadre de leur mission de
contrôle monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
décennie qui vient de s'écouler je crois
nous a appris à faire preuve d'humilité
à faire preuve de pragmatisme dans la
façon de légiférer sur les questions
énergétiques il nous a fallu et il nous
faudra sans doute encore remettre
plusieurs fois l'ouvrage sur le métier
faisons en sorte que cette nouvelle
étape soit un pas supplémentaire qui
nous rapproche de la construction d'un
système électrique où l'énergie sera
sûre compétitive respectueuse de
l'environnement et au service de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie de votre
attention
merci la parole est à Monsieur
jean-Jacques Mirassou
pour le groupe
socialiste madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues tout à l'heure à l'occasion du
débat s'est aperçu qu'on pourrait
disserter sans fin sur ce qui s'est
passé à Barcelone en 2002
mais de ce point de vue-là notre
collègue roland Courteau a apporté une
précision éloquante alors la Commission
européenne fronce le sourcil et la ligne
de partage entre l'opposition et la
majorité elle est très simple d'un côté
il y a ceux qui
entendent répondre avec Zè et célérité
aux injonctions européennes envoy
d'ailleurs au passage l'opportunité de
mettre en fin cette ouverture à la
concurrence
d'df comme ils l'ont fait du reste
précédemment pour la Poste la SNCF et
GDF et au passage en mettant en mal un
service public à la française or d'une
part la concurrence Paris dangereuse
c'est une évidence lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
bien de première nécessité non stockable
et pourtant indispensable notre économie
d'autre part en misant sur la
concurrence et au détriment de tout
mécanisme régulateur cela revient à
casser tous les acquis d'un système
énergétique dont la spécificité n'est
plus à démontrée et qui date ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure de 1945 parceque
issu du Conseil National de la
Résistance de plus la libéralisation du
marché de l'énergie tel queag dans ce
texte risque avoir de lourdes
conséquences pour notre pays en ce qui
concerne par exemple l'aménagement du
territoire et notre outil industriel
l'idéologie mes chers collègues ça a dit
tout à l'heure peut coûter très
cher car cette loi qui impose la
concurrence pourrait et ce n'est pas le
moindre des paradoxes bientôt faire
reflamber la facture d'électricité des
ménages et même si elle prévoit par
ailleurs pour les particuliers un
maintien des tarifs réglementés ceci au
fur et à mesure de la discussion
ressemble de plus en plus en l'heure à
ce jour ce tarif rementé reste très
inférieur à la moyenne des prix
européens et cela constitue la
contrepartie du programme nucléaire
financé par des fonds publ les usagers
contribuables ont donc participé au
financement de ces installations en
bénéficiant en échange la rente
nucléaire autrement dit d'une énergie la
moins coûteuse à produire et qui
représente 80 % de l'électricité
produite en l'Hexagone le scandale de la
loi Nome réside donc dans le fait
qu'elle va transférer cet avantage de la
rente nucléaire bénéficie des
consommateurs aux fournisseurs d'énergie
certaines d'ailleurs ont même parlé de
holdup en effet la loi stipule que DF va
devoir céder pendant 15 ans jusqu'à 25 %
de sa production à ses concurrents à
travers ce que le texte appelle l'accès
régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique or tout en maintenant les
tarifs leugmentés le texte modifie leur
mode de fixation en l'indexant sur le
prix auquel les fournisseurs concurrents
achèteront l'électricité à ADF
concrètement ça veut dire que si ce prix
est élevé les tarifs réglementés le
seront aussi et pour que le tarif
réglementé n'augmente pas il faudrait
qu'EDF cède sa production concurrents à
un tarif bien inférieur à CELI qui a été
évoqué soit 42 € par mgawh mais alors
l'opérateur historique aurait bien du
mal à trouver les manœuvres les marges
de manœuvre pour investir dans de
nouveaux moyens de production la séance
d'hier soir s'est finalement achevée sur
l'exception recevabilité qui a été
rejeté prochain rendez-vous 16h vous
pourrez suivre la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi sur la nouvelle
organisation du marché de l'électricité
et bien sûr tous nos décryptages
politiques et parlementaires sont
disponibles sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne journée sur
notre
chaîne